Everybody!
Hello!
I'm muted.
Yeah, I'm unmuted on Lily's channel.
Yippee!
I like how chat has like the biggest short-term memory.
I literally tell them, I'm unmuted myself real quick to talk
to Doki, and just like, can I do that?
Lily, Lily, why can't you be muted?
You're muted, you're muted!
I'm like, yeah, I just told you I was muted.
Wait, don't people say like like chat reflects the streamer?
No, that's that's so wrong.
No, that's not wrong.
Oh, no, that's wrong Are you trying to say they're dumber
than you or they're smarter than you though?
Whichever one gets me in less trouble Lily's chat are you
smarter or dumber than Lily?
wisely
Don't worry my chat is a pure reflection of me Which is like
we're We're smart We're great at FPS games.
We're so funny.
We're We're so kind we're generous right dragon right right
guys right yeah I'm I'm I too am funny I didn't just spend
like almost two hours talking oh yeah I was listening oh
yeah yeah like yeah you're talking about your cat's
allergies and you're like oh I'm gonna try and see what your
cat your cat's allergic to you but like yeah yeah you know
like how like pets can like suddenly develop allergies as
they get older which is fucked up i it's so annoying to me
yeah i was just like how how do you just suddenly become
allergic like what's wrong with you like who purchased this
dlc stop returning even evolution was not supposed to be
like this i was taught that hundreds and thousands of years
not five years evolution isn't supposed to be this fast how
dare you how dare you evolve backwards stop evolving
backwards yeah but be so fucked up suddenly he's like
allergic I'm like stop just stop being allergic what the
yeah like what the fuck just stop evolving we domesticated
you to not be like this right all these years of
domestication don't fuck it up yeah your ancestors are
disappointed in you looking down at you being like wow this
is what i turned into you used to be a lion lions are not
allergic to fucking kibble like what's wrong with you She
didn't know the cripple was too dry.
She touched my tummy.
Tommy hurt.
Now, Tommy hurt.
You crippled not good.
We had to fight rhinos.
And she's like, back in my day, we fought rhinos.
And now your tummy hurt?
What's wrong with you?
Tommy hurt.
Please love my tummy.
Oh my god.
It's like when our parents go like, they tell stories about,
when I used to go to school.
He has to go through a snowstorm in a blizzard up a hill for
17 kilometers.
But I was your age.
I was hunting rhinos.
Barefoot.
Slides.
Carrying my siblings.
I had to be an only child because we killed off the other
children.
I ate the offspring.
I ate the Austrian ring and now you're gonna throw up in
Lily's bed I can't hold my pee beam I have to pee Kibble is
too dry
Please well hydrate the kibble, please My dog
he evolved into being allergic to chicken after eating
chicken kibble for her to eat he grew up eating chicken
kibble and then out of nowhere he just started being
allergic to chicken oh my god it's like our dogs i don't
know if it was if it was turkey or duck it wasn't chicken
but it was like a different breed turkey or duck yeah can we
always give them like like food left always be like oh yeah
here have little tree you know on the side and suddenly it's
like He's acting really strange.
And I'm like, why?
Turns out suddenly he's allergic to duck or turkey or
whatever the fuck.
Like, oh my God.
I was here.
I had to pay, like, like lots and lots of money at this,
like, specialist, at this, like, allergy specialist to do,
like, an allergy test on my dog.
And then I got the test back.
And he's literally allergic to, like, maple, like, actual,
like, maple trees and grass.
He's, like, allergic to certain types.
of grass and he's allergic to like like certain types of
bugs like he's like oh you oh he shouldn't have any mosquito
bites because he's allergic to mosquitoes i was like what
the fuck is wrong imagine being this majestic wolf but then
it's just like oh you know a grass herdy it's herdy outside
dangerous i don't want to be outside i want to be on couch
inside dog now
I want to be enjoying every time I like take him out for a
walk and I have to like wipe his paws like get like those
like wet wipes and wipe his paws when you can't oh that's
gonna wipe my paws it's time to wipe your paws wow you used
to be a wall nice paw wipey time come here little man I just
want you guys to know chat before we like started the stream
when we were muted Lily was we were talking about the
subcategories of furry
it was a very interesting conversation oh my gosh you guys
should have seen Lily knew so much about like furry culture
it was that what were just subcategories of furries again
Lily I don't remind me again.
I don't I don't remember that one if I remember correct You
were like okay, so like Lily was like yeah, there's like
three subcategories of furries And I was like wow, really?
And she's like, yeah, because your name is dokeybird I was
like, yeah, and she's like yeah, so you're like a feathery
and I was like a feathery What?
This bitch is full of shit
And she was like, yeah, there's like Like a feathery, a
skelly, and like a furry.
And I learned so much, Lily.
I had to educate her real quick.
She was so under-educated.
I know.
I couldn't have that, man.
I couldn't have that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She like educated me so hard about furry culture.
I just had to make sure you're aware.
I care, you know?
Oh, thank you.
I'm so happy that you, like, cared about me so much.
I'm like I don't think she can she can go on living without
knowing yeah yeah like if we're gonna be playing like wolf
quest like I had to I had to know me like subcategories like
how I was like this is a furry no okay I'm playing trying to
create my wolf right now I'm so sad they like there's like
DLC for this game for like better colors and I'm like do it
right yeah I was like why Give me the DLC.
I'm like, do I buy it right now?
Wait, how expensive are they?
How expensive are they anyway to be like different colors?
Bro, they're like $7 to have like a different color coat?
A different color coat.
What a bargain.
What a bargain though.
Like I would pay $7 to be a blue wolf.
Yeah, sure.
You know what?
Maybe I will, maybe I don't, maybe I fucking will, maybe
I'll fucking will, maybe I'll fucking will, maybe I'll be,
maybe I'll be, are you a little bitch?
No, I'm not a coward, I'm buying it right now, I have a
stream of right now.
Boom, boom, agreed purchase.
Did you buy the full DLC pack or did you chicken out on one?
There's like three, there's so many.
it out a little bit i i may have not by the rest maybe you
like the other colors i mean clearly you're gonna come back
to woke quest right you're gonna come clearly i'll i'll buy
some more yeah yeah it's like it's like nike it was for
wolves it's just like nike yes yes for those who don't know
uh in my chat lily is a like not ironically but like she
actually loves nike like it's such a cool game i love it
it's got beautiful big booty anime woman yeah and then like
when you shoot the gun like wow the cutting i like pudding i
like pudding yeah how much money have you spent on nike no
comment come on wait would someone in chat rat you out i
think i think i think nike is like my least spent gotcha.
You're the least, but you stream Niki so much!
Yeah, but it's quite great to play friendly.
I got lucky quite a bit.
Oh my god, wait, okay, so like, then you won't be shy to
tell me how much you spent on Niki if it's your least spent
one, right?
I am.
Well, you see the skins are like very pretty.
Why are you why are you so scared of telling me if it's your
least spent a few hundreds probably a few hundreds like a
day right can you imagine every day i wake up i'm like i
have to swipe my hands are shaking i'm like you're like
you're like 80 of nikki's budget yeah that's it's important
oh my god Like being a blind wolf is a DLC.
That's fucked up.
Why is it?
Why is like a disability a paid DLC?
That's so fucked up.
What the fuck?
You want to be a disabled wolf?
I have to pay to be blind?
What is this like capitalism shit?
Why do I have to pay to be blind?
Oh my god.
I'm sorry, but blind is only for the cool people.
You can only be blind if you have money.
I'm sorry That's just how it goes As such how it goes, man
Oh my god.
Oh shit Everyone can afford being blind Oh my god, the wolf
house There's so many different wolf house You can have
Yeah, I have like a billion voices I'm like, I'm overwhelmed
I have to do The rest of my body freeze.
Oh my god It's just so much going on There's 48 6 wolf house
the same i can't have a color that's so cool let's go well i
can be a chubby wolf oh i can be large yeah i'll be large
extra large you'll be an extra large extra large all right i
got my how i just picked random numbers there's too many
numbers oh i get big ears wait what's this ear modifier What
does that do?
Big ears.
I can have like...
My ears can be like scratched up.
There is tail DLC.
Having tail DLC?
Having snaggled tools as a DLC?
Come on, man.
I just bought a DLC.
You're telling me snagged teeth weren't part of it.
It's time to buy another DLC.
It's time to buy another.
Damn it.
Yeah, don't you want to be cool like all the other wolves?
I'm gaslighting me.
Don't you want to be cool?
Are you want to be a boring NPC wolf or a main protagonist
snaggle too?
I want to be a main protagonist.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I can have like a collar on.
But like, like educational wise.
Educational.
Yeah, education.
An educational college.
it guys it's educational purposes I can be a fat wolf so you
guys know I'm like well fed like I can do my job I want to
be well fed but I want this like little spaghetti tail it
looks so stupid it's a cheek rough with oh I can be oh my
god I'm so fluffy yeah you get to be like a little fluffy
boy oh my god what's this back curve okay no it's gonna be
straight I don't want to have like back problems I don't
want to have back problems.
I don't want to have back problems.
All right.
Oh my god.
The tail is like a cat tail.
Yeah.
It's so cute.
It's so funny.
It's something wrong with this.
With this one.
It's beautiful.
Okay.
Ooh.
A very fluffy.
Okay.
Body shape.
Oh, I'm big.
I'm the alpha.
All right.
I'm the alpha now except physical I'm love oh my god you can
like oh okay we can you can like do your stats and stuff you
must take example one minus one okay I don't need to be true
wait no I should be strong I don't need to be healthy I can
just be strong I don't need to be healthy
I need speed I need maximum speed All right, I'm gonna...
You know, you can be the speedy one.
I'll have the stamina and the strength.
I'll do a minus one on the speed.
I have so much speed, but I will just be wheezing after five
steps.
Like, oh, my name is Doki Wolf.
I...
There's a bio, by the way.
Oh, my God.
I was born...
The bio.
Without a father.
My mother left me and abandoned me.
Oh, yeah.
My mother, thank you, thank you for ghostwriting this for
me.
My mother abandoned me as a young pup.
Casted out by my own family.
She now roams the wilds by herself.
Let me Google the plot of Naruto real quick.
Then I kissed Sasuke.
All right, here you go.
All right.
This is good.
This is it.
I figured out a really good plot, guys.
Can I put the B movie script in there?
Yeah, you can't.
All right.
In response to the leader of, okay, let's see.
Um, okay.
Not Naruto, but Doki Wolf.
Doki Wolf.
Unable to make friends.
She is always sad and lonely.
What is this like?
You know like Mary Sue before Wolves?
This is like a fucking Davian art.
Yeah, yeah.
This is like a sparkle wolf for me.
Herself, a male wolf.
I mean, hello?
It's 2024.
Don't judge my male wolf having a female pronoun.
What the fuck?
Whoa.
Don't go there.
Hey, dude.
This is my original OC.
Do not steal.
All right.
Oh, my God.
W.
I found you a genius.
Just a glimpse.
How do I spell a glimpse?
Into my dark wolf soul.
Inside you there are two wolves.
Wait, what did you name your wolf?
What did you name it?
Wait, what do I name him?
Right.
My wolf is Doki Wolf FPS B2B.
Sad hand job.
Oh.
The sad.
What?
Inside you, there are two wolves.
Sad hand job and Doki Wolf.
Wait, wait, wait.
I've been picking proper names.
Um.
I'm not good with proper names.
How do I pick a proper name?
Sad.
Oh my god, yes.
That's good.
Yeah.
Okay, maybe I should call Doki Wolf Toe.
How do I spell Doki Wolf?
Doki Wolf Toe.
Do you remember the toe?
Like, not Rudo, but...
Oh!
Sasuke and the Doki Wolf Toe.
Okay.
I'll be like...
All right.
No.
Okay.
Wolf toe is social bold and energetic.
What's Iron Wolf?
Lives on the edge.
Always one false move.
Oh my god, is that like the runescape thing where they make
like what was it like the...
Oh!
Yeah!
Probably, yeah.
Yeah, but this time there's a wolf version.
There's a wolf version to this.
Oh my god.
Yeah, it's like Iron Man mode.
Yeah, but for once.
This is crazy.
This is so elaborate.
Yeah.
Okay, continue.
She's obviously cautious, a loner, but so much energy.
Yes, we have.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Should we do story mode, which is we have to raise pups,
territory quest, or pack life?
I don't know which one's good.
The pack would be cool.
Like, what if we just do something wrong and then I just got
killed?
I'm pretty sure it's the same, right?
The story mode, it's like establish a territory or
inventory.
raise pups okay wait chat all you um wolf quest enthusiast
which is the best one for mission what's the best one to
pick yeah yeah which one all right how do you two breed uh
we'll figure we'll find other wolves we'll find other wolves
i mean lily's a female wolf so she can go and find some of
the milk
yas I'll be the dead bee wolf and I'll try to find as many
you know as many wolves as I can to establish a pack we're
gonna make a big pack we're gonna make a huge pack massive
it's fucking massive bro alright I'll do east okay game name
um Wolf Rudeau.
That's our game name.
Okay, do we want easy?
There's an accurate level.
Accurate?
What is accurate?
No, it's fine.
We don't need to have it be accurate.
I'm fine with that.
Major decisions.
I decide.
Okay, set up a game with selected wolf.
Alright.
I'm setting up our I'm setting up my wolf.
I'm creating my multiplayer and then I'll invite you in.
Let's go.
Sage is gonna come in.
Wolf can smell thousands of times.
better than humans whoa oh my god there's me a wolf's life
is fun right now one thing living long enough to raise the
next wait i'm gonna die joki woto is gonna die okay to raise
the next generation which will carry their genes in the
future all else from hunting elk to defending a territory
drives towards the single goal now your pack which consists
of two parents and perhaps several pack as adults, can try
to realize this goal.
The survival of the new literal pups and the survival of
your genetic code will be your responsibility.
Oh, shit.
Okay, how do I invite you?
My bloodline ends with me.
But you wanted that happen!
I have no family.
I am sad skin.
My family has cast me out that I'm unable to love.
Oh my god, sad skin!
No!
Can you join my game or like do I have to do that?
Wait, I have to find you.
Wait, what's your username on?
What's your username on WolfQuest?
Oh, wait.
It should be that.
Alright.
Let me see.
Wait, I found Claire.
Oh, okay.
I sent you a request.
What the fuck's the request?
You have to look at your friends or account, I think.
save your world so don't lose it yeah i saved it yeah i
remember to say my bio yes accept all right waiting i'm
waiting for i'm waiting for satsuke i have no friends yet no
friends friendless friendless i have to change my bio i have
friends now maybe i can't feel love again oh my god
character growth wait you're not in i don't see you you're
at my friendless now.
Wait, I'm... Wait, wait.
Can you join via my... Can you join from me?
I can only message you.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay.
I found you.
Oh, okay.
Wait, wait.
Create a new pack.
I'm friend and I'm...
Damn.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
All right.
I'm going to create a new pack right now.
Now add players.
Okay.
I'm going to add you.
I'm figuring this game out live right now.
We're doing it live.
Yeah, okay, here.
think we got it waiting waiting did you get it i added you
to my pack
uh it's probably somewhere it says you're in there oh wait
oh oh maybe like oh maybe it just shows up on my screen guys
how do i add people to my server how do we play together we
play together guys this is the most important part what the
heck all you wolf quest enthusiasts how do you someone has
to know someone must have no must have played this game for
at least 50 hours i know you exist i know come on you have
to you're in there somewhere i know you're here here
somewhere no idea How do I have to be played together?
How do we play together?
This is the most important part.
Imagine we fail here.
Like, this is the first difficulty hurdle.
We just fail and play together.
We just don't even know how to join the server.
I can't do it.
It's like, anyway.
Elk.
I literally made...
Okay, wait.
I'm going to return the main menu.
I'm going to end my session.
and then I'll I can quit a new world so easily I have all
the power all right it never even oh no wait to the pack
Lily the furry yes yes I would love to join Lily the furry
pack nice oh you go to join okay okay I figured it out I
figured it out okay I'm in it now I think it just takes a
long no I just I deleted the world so you're not in it
you're not in it I deleted the world I made it, never mind.
Okay, okay, okay.
Do not worry.
I'm fixing this.
I put this on easy.
Okay, I set up my game with Selected Wolf.
Okay, let me see.
What do I...
Okay, Doki Rudo.
All right, that's the world.
Okay, you go to Join Multiplayer Game.
You click New Game.
Join Multiplayer Game.
And then you should see Doki Rudo, I think.
Start Game of Selected.
so you see the single player you change to join multiplayer
world yeah i clicked something wrong help oh oh okay okay
okay okay okay new game you guys can look at my cool wolf
while we new game step by step join multiplayer oh we have
rules no profanity dokey thank you very much thank you no no
problem
please behave please behave yeah yeah this is a PG PG stream
by the way no profanity in my wolf world we don't want the
we don't want the admins to come in here and ban us from
wolf quest guys exactly yeah yeah I will be so devastated if
my wolf got banned oh my my hours and money she spent DLC
money guys DLC you can't ban me someone's like this is a
Christian pack my dad works for Nintendo and he will find
you he'll turn off your switch forever where is Sasuke what
server do I join I like Yuki Rudo East?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
It's the U.S.
East one.
Oh, Doki Rudo.
Yeah, yeah.
There's only one Doki Rudo world.
Oh.
Shit.
Oh, I got Sasuke.
Oh, Sasuke!
Oh, you're here.
I'm still loading.
What the hell?
You're here.
Damn you.
Oh, my God.
Do you have a collar on?
Oh, you're domesticated.
You look like an actual domesticated.
You look like a fucking dog.
My father and brethren I have been carrying this around for
years Oh, yeah, Masaryll, you can see oh my god, you look
like a fucking dog What's wrong with your ears?
Like a rat tail.
Yeah, what's wrong with your fucking ear?
Okay, I need to look at the a cow that I need to look at the
What's wrong with you?
My ears are just a little crooked, man.
What the heck?
You're shaming me?
Yeah, I'm ear shaming you.
Tantel shaving you and collar shaming you.
I'm going to look at the controls.
Okay, let's see.
Okay.
Oh, I can sit down.
There's emotes.
There's a head cam.
Wait.
Establish your territory.
Can I pee on you?
Excuse me?
Wait, it's on pee.
Just lift the leg real quick.
Wait, wait.
Wait, is there?
Yeah!
What I'm establishing my territory.
I'm just establishing.
Don't mind me.
Yeah, yeah, don't mind me.
I know what's my territory.
Excuse me.
I am bigger than you.
Sasuke.
You cannot win in this fight.
Wait, I can.
I can sleep.
Oh my god, I'm sleeping.
Oh my god.
I'm sleeping.
Okay, what's the emotes?
I'm eating Wait, there's like play wait, oh press hold E and
you can emote I can't roll My tail wag is so gross I have
like a fucking rat tail
What is what is submissive?
Okay, what's airplane years?
Oh my god, I'm just like you now now you can be just like
you you know that says oh uncertain oh avert gaze oh but
wait what's the body there's like sniff nose confident i can
sniff you okay wait i can lick face wait why can't i lick
you i can't oh my god okay wait let's see i can smile your
butt wait are you sniffing my butt Wait, are you actually...
I think it's body.
No, there's sniff noses.
There's no sniff butt.
Sniff nose.
Yeah, why sniff butt?
This game is not accurate.
Maybe it's a DLC.
But sniffing DLC.
All right.
What is our...
What even is our purpose?
We were supposed to establish territory and, like, raise
our...
raise pups.
Our purpose is revenge.
Revenge.
We need to find her Sakura.
I also failed us.
Sasuke, we need to find her Sakura.
We need to find her Sakura.
She cheated on me with Naruto.
Oh, well, wait, that's, it's not cheating.
Look, you guys.
It's not cheating.
Sasuke, we told you this.
This is an open relationship.
I never agreed
Alright, let's see Where do we go?
Where do we go?
Wait, no, I'm the leader Okay, follow me Follow me It's not
cheating if there are two wolves inside Oh my god, you're
right!
It's not cheating if there are two wolves inside of her
Inside of me there are two wolves Yo, what's this?
We need to find a den.
Wait, we can eat.
A den?
Yeah.
We need to find like a place to establish our territory.
Wait, where are you?
Where did you go?
I think I'm hunting something.
I'm not sure how.
Oh my god, you're hunting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, don't worry.
Alright.
When hold to press- Oh, I can bite him!
Okay.
How do I bite him?
Oh, okay.
She just lets me bite him.
Alright, you just press spacebar.
Oh, a space bar.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Space bar.
Oh, don't worry.
I'm hunting too.
I'm injured.
I'm injured?
What are you hunting?
I'm, I'm fucking hunting a fucking cat.
I'm hunting like a little fox.
A little fox?
There's like a shot.
Dude, this cat's bigger than me.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Nom, nom, nom.
Oh my God, how much HP do you have?
I'm just biting his butt relentlessly.
Oh, I think I'm dead.
wait what oh wait wait no no no i'm okay i'm okay i'm okay i
was like what the heck are you a missing wins okay i'm you
know what this gets cougar wins this cougar is way too
strong whoa win definitely not me oh my god you're so far
make markings into sand spot mark it again to boost your
claim it how do i mark something p Oh, how convenient.
Can I pee on my food?
Wait, wait.
Why are you peeing on your food?
I have to mark it as mine.
It's, yep, that's mine now too.
Wait, I'm going to mark this tree.
You can't do that.
I'll reclaim it.
No, no, no, no.
Too soon return.
I have to reinforce the setpost and boost your claim.
Oh, I can express myself.
I can express myself.
Pag rally.
We're our Wolf brethren
Rally achieved Nice look at us We're like How do we eat
this?
How do we eat this?
We want to eat this fox I spent all this time killing him I
know How do you eat it?
This is important We're starving We're starving Help Help
guys we need to know How do we eat this?
Can we just leave it to die?
What the?
What are you doing?
Eat it!
I don't know.
We catch canines?
We can't.
So we killed him for no reason?
Why can't I eat canine?
Of course I can.
I'm a wolf.
Of course I can eat canine.
I know.
Who cares?
Like, what the...
Who cares what I'm eating?
I don't know that we're leaving.
Clearly, you're not as good of a hunter as you say you are.
my bad my my be i guess i'll kill like an elk or something
who knows what's that over there is that an elk wait there's
an elk oh oh stranger you're entering a territory of a
stranger wolf territory that i call market is mine yeah if i
mark it it's not the strangers anymore yeah boom it's mine
now yeah sorry it's looking sorry not sorry yeah it's our
territory now
deer damage?
Wait, where the fuck is the deer?
I feel like we need a home, Lily.
I feel like we need a home.
We need a home.
I don't like this.
I don't like that we're just loner wolves trying to fucking
steal food.
Where the fuck?
How do we establish a home?
Take over a territory find sense spots in this hex.
Mark it to reduce the claim.
An establish home.
This game is much more elaborate than I expected it to be.
Right?
I thought it was That would be easy.
I have to actually use my brain here.
What the heck?
Are you still peeing on trees?
Wait, is it still...
Yeah, I'm trying to find...
I'm trying to find the scent spots.
How do I find...
Oh, oh, it is...
We found food?
Numb, numb, numb, numb.
Oh, my God.
He's strong, he's strong, he's strong.
Don't worry.
If we can kill him together.
Kill him together.
Kill him, kill him.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Numb, numb, numb, numb.
Yeah, that's like there's two of us.
What are you going to do?
Yes.
Yes, that's what you're right.
Om nom nom.
He's single now.
Let's get him.
Let's go.
That's good.
I might be dying.
I think I'm dying, Lily.
Don't die.
We must kill the smooth before I die.
I have a major injury.
I fractured my leg.
I'm fractured.
Just don't be weak.
Don't have a fractured leg.
Do you not have a fractured leg?
I have a fractured leg.
I'm on his leg.
Let's go.
It's okay.
It's half HP.
Where are you?
I'm gonna die.
I'm limping.
I'm literally limping.
Alright, I'll watch.
That's right.
But I watch.
Don't worry.
You got this.
I'll howl for you.
Howl.
Die.
I'm gonna watch.
Oh my god, he hit me in the head.
not touch my bowl oh my god don't worry i'll sit here and
watch i believe in you this is my own home theater i have no
stamina oh my god no no no no i need to find something
satsuki i need to eat kill him for me i'm getting his food
don't worry i'm getting it i'm getting it holy shit what is
your hp i told you i'm a big chonker You're so...
Alright, don't let it get away!
Oh, wait, I can help out now!
I can help out!
Don't worry!
Numb, numb, numb, numb, numb, numb!
Numb, numb, numb!
We will eat you!
We will eat you if it's the last thing we do!
Oh my god, he's like almost half...
He's like one-fifth...
I need his chocolate!
Oh my god!
Come on, we're so close!
Almost there!
It will fix my leg!
Come on!
Oh, they say...
Okay, I'm fucked up right now.
I need to chill.
I'm fucked up So close to dying.
Holy shit.
No, no, no, it's so close.
Never give up.
What would Zatskiss say?
One more.
Please.
Oh, he's like 1 HP.
He's like 1 HP.
He's 1 HP.
Come on.
Yes!
All right, it's time to eat.
No gore, low gore or more gore.
More, you know what?
More gore.
Yeah.
oh these claws are eating food do not oh okay how do i eat
it and then press oh okay how do i eat this okay i think
yeah space space space space how to remember carcass you may
want to return to this carcass how to remember oh okay okay
okay oh yeah
can i eat the crow can i eat the crow carnivores so it
should be fine oh i can like pick it up okay to rest sit
down and then press okay i'm gonna sleep good night how do i
eat what i picked up i think it's like to like we we have a
den we can like uh uh like store store our food or something
i'm pretty sure all right sleep we need to heal
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
No, he's really just, we're just eating.
Are we, are we, are we healed?
Oh my god, the sun is gone!
It is so dark.
Oh my god, it's nighttime.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Oh, we did it.
Why are we still fucked up?
That is little.
I healed so little.
I mean, I barely healed.
What?
I healed like 10%.
Wait, what is this?
What is this bush?
Shit!
We killed our moose and this is all we get?
I still have a broken paw.
Damn.
Wait, I forgot to eat.
It's because I forgot to eat.
Oops.
I didn't eat.
How to heal.
Wait.
Oh, if you press R.
Yeah, yeah, but I didn't even eat.
Ah.
Oh, it takes hunger and then ah.
Am I eating?
Okay.
I'm eating.
Don't worry.
Food will cure your broken leg.
We don't need medicine.
This is home remedies.
Alright.
I'm eating as much as I can.
You can use quick heal.
Yeah, you press R repeatedly.
You can quick heal.
Oh, the orange bar is our food reserve.
I'm learning so much.
See, I knew there were furries in this chat.
I knew how to play this game.
I knew it.
I knew you guys knew.
I knew you guys know how to play this game you guys
pretended I'm eating his butt all right I am healing now oh
my god oh wait that was a rabbit oh no no don't kill them
they they're not food it doesn't matter they're not like
wait it's a rabbit I'm gonna get extra food num num I
sleep all right are you sleepy all right we'll wake up when
the sun's out when you find a house how else are we gonna
raise pups we don't have a home for them you're homeless
what the heck wait my leg is so fucked up what the heck
Let's find a den We'll come back to this later Take a piece
of meat Just like a travel bag You're like Yeah like a
travel bag I don't want to get like Yeah let me grab a
travel bag real quick A doggy bag All a moose to go you know
Yeah yeah just a little moose to go Alright let's find a den
There has to be a den Okay how do we sniff out a den I think
we just have to like Go around until we find a cave I'm
pretty sure Alright let's go There has to be a cave
somewhere.
It shouldn't be so hard to find, right?
It's like all the snow.
Like, it cannot be all the nature.
There has to be holes somewhere.
There has to be a cave.
That's what nature's for.
Right?
Okay.
All I see is snow.
That's all I...
It's just snow, bro.
It's just snow and trees.
What's the point of saving the environment if it's just snow
and trees?
What even is the point, man?
What's the point?
I don't even get Wi-Fi.
I know.
Useless.
Where am I supposed to?
I can't store food in my tree.
I'm not fucking squirre.
I want to have, like, pouches, like dog pouches.
And dog pouches.
Door, everything in my dog pouch.
Well, you should have, like, evolved to have thumbs.
Does that be allergic to shit?
having thumbs oh my god just that's so sad imagine not
having opposable thumbs why is it all just snow i need to
mark more territory i peed on so many things i didn't drink
enough water for this like i only have so much pee in my
mouth i can't keep marking territory what the heck man
there's there's not enough water here for all these trees
god the snow is deep holy shit oh my god there's so much no
fine i'll pee twice they're like yo don't pee just once you
gotta pee twice i might pee twice oh my god i lost satsuke
where's satsuke no i'll come back satsuke oh i found you and
why oh my god i got you Oh my god, okay.
Yay!
We're still out here trying to find a cave.
Dude, what the fuck is the cave?
Where's the cave?
Oh my god, look at the fucking path you made.
It's pretty.
I can make a penis in the snow.
Oh yeah?
Me too.
Who was the biggest snow penis?
As if you didn't do it already?
I would never do such a thing This is a Christian wolf
server This is a Christian only server No profanity allowed
It's called a willy It's a willy It's a wee It's a wee It's
a wee wee Why is Lily so fast?
Because I had I like reduced my speed for a string invested
in speed I invested in strength I knew speed was going to be
important oh my god where's the cave there's no holes
anywhere it's just wait what reached the border you reached
a border oh are we at the edge of the map oh we're in the
edge of the map oh holy shit oh we had to claim more
territory wait okay well okay okay we have to okay we have
to go back i think i think we have to go back okay we have
to go back to all the stuff we we peed on wait wait yeah go
back to our to the moose i think i understand something i
have to investigate real quick okay okay i think i'm
smelling things you're smelling things smelling yeah i'm
gonna go i think i'm smelling okay okay I'm following I'm
following the icon to figure out what it is I'm smelling
maybe it's a den who knows what am I smelling well there's
so many smells what are all these smells so many smells it's
so far away I thought it was gonna be much closer what oh my
god wait why is this one so far away there's like a prawn
horn a snowshoe hair in your oh I'm telling you so many
things.
This is how it works.
Do I pee on the smell now?
Yes!
I figured out the game!
You figured it out!
How?
So, that was this icon on the map and I just peed on the
icon.
And now...
I just peed on it.
And now it's mine.
It's just that easy, guys.
It's just...
Just pee on it.
There's a coyote.
Yeah, I've marked it as mine.
Now I have to wait again to reinforce my mark.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let me...
Okay, I'll come to you.
All right, I'm gonna pee as well.
Just in case.
Just to make sure.
Yeah, I'm just in case.
I just need to make sure.
I just need to make sure I have this post.
You know, it's like double tap, but for pee.
Double tap.
But double pee, just like, two beams.
Yeah, yeah.
I hear wolves.
You?
Are you howling?
No.
That's done our woes.
I hear howls.
That's not our woes.
That's not...
We can convert woes into our pack, though.
Yeah, yeah, I'll howl back.
Where are they?
Friendly.
Wait, wait, wait.
I don't...
Force them to join our pack.
If you look at the map, I'm quite a bit away from you.
Because I followed the...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna keep peeing.
I'm gonna...
We need more...
We need more territory.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just going to keep peeing on stuff.
Just keep peeing.
Oh, above 50%.
It's most efficient to let hex drop to 30 since you can
boost him to 100% one action.
On your marking trip, visit as many hexes in a short trip as
possible.
When can we have a home?
I just want to have a home and make puppies.
Like, that's...
I thought I thought I thought I'd breed.
What if it just steal someone's puppies?
guide okay but to steal somebody's puppies we need to find
the puppy yeah i was so close to finding the walls where did
they go i hurt them and then they know they got where are
you i'm wait let me see i can find you okay oh satsuki's
over here okay i'm going head over yeah i'm asking i'm
hiding over come quickly family family family family okay
show pack territories oh that's our pack
board game what is this oh yeah what the heck yeah look at
these tiles it reminds me like fucking what risk yeah this
is this is this goes deep what's the holy shit you mean for
honestly for two walls having three of that is like pretty
nice not gonna lie i would say so too right we have three of
these territory man bro we have to like remark territory
Okay, we need more wolves in this pack.
We need more wolves.
Where does the other wolves go?
Where are these other wolves?
We want to steal your children.
I don't want to steal.
Please give up your first boy for me.
For us.
How are we going to start a pack if we can't steal your
kids?
Oh, I found something to Mike.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, pee on it.
Pee on it.
Pee, me too.
Let me pee just in case.
Just in case.
Alright.
Nice.
We got it.
Okay, we have to find a den.
If we find a den, maybe there will be already kids inside.
Like a Christmas present?
Santa just brought us kids?
Yeah, yeah.
We're Santa.
We're Santa taking away the kids.
Remember, don't be naughty.
Or Santa's gonna come over and take your children.
Santa, why is your sack empty?
Don't worry, young boy.
It will not be empty for very long.
He'll be full suit.
Just hop on in.
Don't worry, just hop on in.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't think about it.
Okay, maybe we go the right set.
Oh, okay, we gotta...
Why is it always snowing here?
I'm...
Right, where the heck is a den?
How do I...
Why can I live out of den, man?
All these wolves, they're hibernating.
What the fuck are we supposed to do?
Right?
What do I go to find?
Okay, maybe I zoom in.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna head straight.
There must be a cave right there.
I'm gonna head straight down.
I'm not hungry anyway.
I will find...
I will find a hole.
I'm like, oh, you say straight down, but your walking line
is anything but straight.
It's straight!
What do you mean?
It is so straight.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Yeah, that is definitely a straight line.
Oh, you're talking about.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Maybe there's something wrong with your eyes.
You know?
Maybe I did buy the blind eye DLC.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got blind eye DLC.
Oh, wait, there's some scents.
An oil lamp.
A cougar.
Oh, an elk herd is nearby.
Okay, we don't...
What's this red?
oil lamp thing.
It stopped snowing.
I don't see the red oil lamp.
That's only you.
If you hold V, you press V.
Do you see the question mark?
Yeah, what the heck?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm following it.
I'm gonna follow it.
Ground sense.
Pick up the object.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's a collectible!
A collectible!
Oh, how do we pick it up?
We just grab it?
We'll just grab it?
You grab it?
Holds?
Oh, I just health space right now we have a lamp we have a
lab all right we don't have a home but we have a lamp
achievements all right there's a there's a deer right here
where the fuck are the holes if we travel hard enough we
will find a cave that is our we end stream when we find a
cave that will be it we will get the cave we we get the cave
and then we end Street.
It's like, anyway, thanks for watching.
Thanks for watching.
We have a house now.
So like...
I'm sorry, but I have a house now.
I'm better than that.
I swear to God, I swear to God, I'm gonna like save this
game and then open the server and then have like our friends
see just out of the play.
I just, I just go like, oh, Chad, wouldn't it be funny to
like check back into the game game?
There's a freaking mansion.
We just opened the survey.
I was like, all right, all right, let's do it Oh, you 50
hour wolf plus wolf pack player Do it be so funny You think
I'm bluffing?
I will do I did before I'm done.
I fucking outsourced to my tragoons I'm not ashamed
Distinguished gentlemen, welcome to my to my humble mansion
did some mining off stream some casual off stream mining
yeah i'm pissing this i'm making this mine you're making
this random piece of snow yours me too i don't know it was
mine it was it was peeable for some reason i like how
someone in my chat was like why aren't you peeing?
Why aren't you peeing?
Why aren't you establishing territory?
Fine, I'm gonna pee!
Okay, okay, pee, pee, pee.
Territory, territory.
I got this, don't worry.
Don't worry, I got this.
Don't worry.
If we don't find...
If we don't find a house, I swear, in the next 10 minutes,
server's gonna be open.
We're gonna open this server and you're gonna help us find
the house we're you know dragoons and we wish what your fans
called they uh that they call themselves shrimps yeah
dragoons shrimps unite find lily and then tokia cave like
find me a cave young ones and the babies now make babies for
us make babies for me the shrimps and the dragoons the
shrimp goons create the shrimp goons create oh god if i'm
going to shrimp goon cave what the heck we require shrimp
goons now how the heck do i find surely there is a system as
to how to find a cave surely there is wait wait first we
have to pee on this tree before good enough someone yells at
pee on the stream real quick i don't want to get yelled at
let me you can't see but i peed i peed let's see all right
oh look at our territory now we have four hexagons i don't
know what we're doing we expanded see we expanded oh my god
abandoned burrows made by wolves foxes and coyotes just need
to be expanded to your knees okay we have of fun.
We have never seen holes before.
What do you mean?
We're looking for holes everywhere.
There is no holes anywhere.
Keep peeing, Ducky.
Okay, we're gonna keep peeing.
Oh my god.
How do I have all this water?
Too soon.
So it's like you need to... You got Min Max.
Min Max the piss bean.
Can't be in mid and max.
Alright, alright, alright.
Okay, fine.
I'll pee on this next tree I find.
Right here.
That should be a hexagon right here.
Boom.
Alright.
Get peed on.
Here you go.
Wait, what is my purple bar?
What is your...
Yeah, what is...
Is that a pee bar?
What is that?
What is it?
Is it my pee bar?
What is the purple bar?
Yeah.
Oh, it's a rest bar.
It means we will need rest when it's too low.
We have to eat.
All right.
I'm going to make sure I pee on all of this just to be sure.
I'm making it mine.
It's ours now.
How do I save my game?
There's so many questions.
Oh, wait.
There's a fox.
If I scare him, maybe he will leave me till his burrow.
Oh, that's true.
take it make him take us to his kids we don't have wolf kids
we just have like fox kids just adopted him top the fox we
will raise them to be a wolf exactly holy shit look at all
these trees he's so fast right run home he's so fucking fast
just invite us to your children all right here i'm gonna pee
on this too real fast this entire game is just us fighting
trees okay oh my god it's just a sorry it's a peak simulator
yes yeah wait okay how do i i'm gonna see but i'm gonna open
the server yeah how do i shout out we want babies we would
have puppies we want trip goods We need the shrimp goons.
I don't want to save this game.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, save game.
I save.
Okay, I'm saving game.
Found it.
Okay, did I?
Okay.
Shrimp goons.
Help us.
Okay, I'm going to make the loop.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I'm going to remake the lobby.
Help us.
We're so lost.
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna return to the main menu i'm gonna
end the session yes yes open it up almost has left the game
open the gates up all right shrimp goons i know someone here
on wolf quest anniversary edition all right public it's
public now we can have three shrimp goons in here let's go
all right okay well I'll do no chat just in case just to be
safe just to be safe okay okay okay okay join join before
the shrimp goose get in first wait no no don't join don't
join don't join I didn't create it yet do not join I'm
joined I'm joined all right we're fine wait where are you
Okay, yippee Yeah, all right, shrimp goons.
Oh my god.
There's already wolves here Yo, that's great.
Teach us.
Teach us MC
Teach us teach us How does this work?
My leg has been broken for a while How does this work?
Be submissive.
I am the alpha.
I don't know what I'm doing Be submissive on your knees
That's right.
Lie down and show me your belly.
Show me your belly.
Show us your belly.
Just lift my butt.
Go ahead, lift my butt.
Where's the belly?
Where's the submissiveness here?
Yeah, where's the, what the heck?
Where's the submissiveness?
Oh, that's right, yeah.
That's right, yeah.
That's right.
all right we have our pack this is our pack now i am the
alpha that teaches how to play the game find dirt and ditsy
let's go that's right i am i know i disabled chat but like
show us how to play without talking you may you may be peed
on once you find us a beautiful home Yeah, finally, all
right, let's pee on all of them to make sure they are our
territory.
Yeah, I peed on them.
I'm peed on them.
First pee, and then I'll be...
So immersive.
We're so immersive.
Now find us at home.
We want a home right now.
I'm bringing it home.
find us a home okay follow dirt he knows what to do he's
running in the direction dirt knows look at the confidence
drive in him calm yeah I know it that's when you know this
guy has 50 hours on wolf quest anniversary edition that's
when you know that's when you know that's right dirt go go
dirt go dirt go you got Yeah, you got this dirt.
You have to find a safe place to sleep.
We need puppies.
We need shrimp goons.
When a shrimp and a dragon, like each other very, very much.
Wait, who's the bottom?
Is it the shrimps or the goons?
I mean, it's in the name, so...
It couldn't be more obvious.
you okay dirt where is our home where is our home okay did
see it so far away this person did not invest in speed
that's for sure they are not speedy they're not speedy at
all where is there i feel like you know it would be fucked
up if dirt actually doesn't know what we're doing and he's
just ready to strip he's like why are you guys following me
Don't worry.
He must know what he's doing.
Oh damn, Fang gotta kill.
Okay, okay.
Oh, shit.
He's just going for it.
Go.
Go, Wolf.
No, I'm following dirt.
You've gone far too long without sleeping.
Oh shit, guys.
I'm gonna sleep.
I'm EP.
I'm OP too.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Body heat.
Grab me, the body heat.
all these everybody's just like stops on the tracks of sleep
just come sleep guys the sun is still up why are you guys
not sleeping yeah the sun is up what the heck yeah what the
fuck sleep the alpha says sleep it's middle of the day what
the heck go go eat go sleep what are you doing i'll kick you
out if you don't sleep that was quick sleep or kik sleep or
kik i shall sleep all right nice me me me me me me me
and then listen real quick all right there we go there we go
oh is that food for me that's right feed the alpha fan put
that food down right now What?
Put that food down right now.
I'm hungry.
He just shook his head.
No way!
Oh my god!
You bitch!
I can replace you.
How do I express myself?
Snarl.
Yeah, yeah, snarl.
Grr.
Eat or kick.
Feed or kick.
Bang.
My ears are already airplane.
I'll wait.
How do I un-airplane my ears?
You were born like that.
I was born.
I'm a natural airplaneer.
Wait, what happened to dirt?
Yeah, wait, what is dirt?
Where the fuck is dirt?
Oh, I got dirt.
It's the one that knows where the fucking holes are.
Dirt, where are you?
He knows about holes.
He has the whole location.
No, dirt.
No, where is dirt?
Wait, where is dirt?
Oh, dirt found a home!
Wait, for real?
Yeah, he's found a home!
Where are you?
Yo!
I'm coming, I'm coming!
I'm behind you, I'm behind you!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Dirt found him straight down!
He found him!
That's your fang and MC!
You guys can never live up to dirt.
Dirt MVP.
You guys could never.
Yeah, you guys could never live up to the expectations we
have now.
Yeah.
Dirt has said bars you wouldn't comprehend.
Yeah, you wouldn't comprehend.
This is the standard now.
This is our proud child.
Oh my god!
This is...
You know why it's better than...
That's a hole?
How do we get in?
What the heck?
How do we...
Dirt, you know what?
Dirt?
That's what I expected from a collared wolf.
From a collared wolf.
From a fucking collared wolf.
You're just never meant to be wild That's the king right
Show me your belly How do I make it mine?
Do I pee on it?
Yeah, you gotta pee on it.
Okay, me too.
Peep on the house to make a noise.
You're just not like us.
You're not savage enough like us.
Wait, did you just eat the...
Oh!
I ate the whole thing.
What the heck?
I guess I was hungry.
Holy shit.
So how do we...
Let me look at the map real fast.
Is that our dead?
Is this ours?
Show all dead.
Yeah, it is.
It's ours!
Is it ours?
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, make this our territory, guys.
Start peeing.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Start peeing around the trees.
Sorry.
Just start...
Make it ours pee.
Pee everywhere.
I think that's because I said collied wolf.
got worse please the wolf community do not cancel me do not
cancel oh an uncolored i cannot believe donkey breadman's
one of the colored wolf she has no idea where this came from
oh my god she doesn't know the meaning behind it i am sorry
i don't i'm just an uncolored wolf i don't know it's like i
cut her some slack she doesn't know better i don't I'm not
wearing a collar.
I don't know It's ours.
We did it.
It belongs to us.
Is it belongs to us?
This is our home now?
It is belongs to us.
Oh my god.
Our home.
We did it.
We complete the quest.
So how do we get pups?
Now four weeks ago, your pups are too big.
Okay, guys.
Shrimp goons.
Shrimp goons, come over here.
Make pups.
Strip goons We have another Request Now make the puppy Make
a puppy Come here and make a puppy Make a puppy for us to
see Wait who's this Wait it doesn't have a name anymore Who
is this wolf?
What has it for me?
What?
Wait you have a name?
Yeah it's Ditsy Oh Ditsy oh I actually pressed N I pressed N
and I did Yeah press and it's gone immersion mode oh my god
it makes me so immersed okay no let me look at the controls
let me let's see how do we make a puppy how do we make the
puppies i thought when we put two puppies together it would
just work is there more to that done is there is there is
there more to that than we expect what the heck This isn't
everything?
That's not it?
There's more?
What do you mean?
This isn't everything?
I can't believe you guys don't have bios.
How are we supposed to know your story?
Where's your bio?
What's that like?
I'm reading it.
Only like Sasuke and Doki Wolf FPS VTuber has a bio.
Why is there no bio?
You don't take this game seriously.
Yeah, you guys don't take this.
You're not as immersed as us.
All right, give us pee on more things.
We need more hexes.
Sasuke and I are just going to have these satsuton while you
guys pee everyone.
Just keep peeing while we chat.
No, we're chatting next to our home.
Just, yeah, failed our pee.
Go, go pee.
We peed it up.
Breeding and bile.
I'm ready to make puppies.
Yeah, it's okay.
I'm ready for puppies.
I feel like I feel like I've matured enough.
I like how we've like outsourced.
Oh, I love my food.
Fang, put that down.
I'm hungry.
Your alpha is hungry.
That's right.
Show me your belly, Fang.
Come back.
belly dial and show me your belly all right how do i make my
tail go up wait that looked so goofy oh wait what the fuck
what the fuck that looks so fucked up wait it's my antennas
where you can see me oh my god this looks so stupid i like
how we're like we like we like outsourced the help now and
we don't we don't need do anything this is the goal of being
a streamer yeah like we get food now we have a home we get
food we get territory yeah and then all we have to do
another piece they got us another hexagon yes oh my god
ditzy what are you doing why are you still in this hexagon
leave this hexagon and go
We need like, we need like, like 8 out of 15.
I can't do quick maths.
Quick maths.
We need seven more hexagons.
Didsy leave.
What the heck?
It's in the quest.
If you press M, oh.
If you press M and you see establish your territory, it
tells you how many hexagons you need.
Ah.
I see.
Four hexagons?
Come on.
Hop up.
We won the more.
We gave you guys four hexagons already.
So it's up to you now.
It's like you started with like three.
Two times.
We traveled to this area to have a future for all you shrimp
goons.
We made this happen.
We made this happen for you shrimp goons.
You should be grateful.
Yeah.
Back in our day, we didn't even have hexagons to start off.
Back in our day, we had to pee multiple tons of water for
one hexagon.
Yeah, yeah.
Now it leaves you pissed two trees.
Yeah, and now you guys have it so easy.
It's so easy.
Known wolf.
We're having known wolf?
This wolf was known to you who's now known to us okay how do
we can give him a nickname all right what is his name he's
like uh he's probably nicknames one four zero five oh you go
to known wolves and then you type his name okay non-wolves
why don't we name him what do you name one four zero five
wolf Let's see That's a good question UTI What Wait it
actually changed Where I see it It's global No way No No
Okay All right this one we have two more to name the other
one will i need remember to seal their puppies and then oh
wait that's it wait is it oh wait no that's the mail that's
a mail okay okay oh m is male m is male okay okay okay okay
okay uh take back for puppies there you go all right we
gotta get that we gotta get that one like for puppies yeah
yeah yeah we gotta get that one we gotta get that we gotta
we gotta claim this one all right here we go all right we
gotta get that that wolf guys bring that wolf to us we
request that wolf oh not the uti one i would not the uti
wolf not the uti wolf we want to we want to we want to take
that wolf's puppies
Find her home and take her puppies.
That's all we want.
We just want a puppy.
We take care of it.
I promise.
We just want, yeah, we're better parents.
We're better parents.
Look at this.
We can lately.
We're such better parents.
We have an oil lamb.
Come on.
Do they have an oil lamb?
I don't fucking think so.
Take her puppy.
I need her.
Okay, guys, remember.
We're taking her puppy.
This woes puppies.
That's all we want.
Get the puppy.
Have they claimed more territory?
Ditsy, what are you doing?
There's like two hexagons next to you.
What?
What are you doing, Ditsy?
Are you all peeing?
You've been in that hexagon for so long.
Why can't you be more like dirt?
Visit.
I think Ditsy.
Let's go to Ditsy.
Are we going the right way?
I have no idea what the heck's did see.
Okay, I'm looking.
Yeah, yeah, this way, this way.
Let's see, I swear.
If we hit that hexagon before you make that hexi ours, I
swear.
We're gonna kick you out.
There's gonna be consequences, young man.
There's gonna be consequences for your action.
Oh, wait, I need to sleep.
Good night.
Oh, shit, me too.
Good night, baby.
No, don't leave me alone.
Good night.
Okay, wait.
I forgot to sleep.
What was the button again?
Zed.
Zed, okay.
Sleep.
Everybody, sleep.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Whoa, who's that?
What was that?
Who's that had popped up next to us?
Wait, what?
Somebody popped up next to us.
Who the fuck is that?
I don't have one.
Wait, do you have like a ghost vault or something?
Yeah, a ghost vault that showed up.
Holy shit Hello there mother Mother Nourish me Me Nourish me
Mother Me
Someone's not sleeping Who is not sleeping Who is that?
There will be consequences Who's not sleeping?
You think I won't know If you're not sleeping or not?
Don't make me pull up the map We will find Ya We have fires
everywhere Oh my god Yay The day is going now Yeah Yeah Yeah
What a beautiful night sky gone.
Nice that did see oh did see is here Oh my legs healed.
Okay, that was did see next to us.
Let's see you didn't claim that other hexagon You're running
away How dare you how dare you you wake up and you just
right you you have a trail we can find you I can smell you
from a mile away.
We're going to supervise your work now, Ditsy.
We can't judge like, yes, okay.
Nice arc on that stream.
Yes, yes.
All right, we're going to...
All right, Ditsy, we're going to be your supervisors.
Ditsy, I swear to God, if we get there and you're not
peeing.
Okay, nice.
Good pee.
Ditsy, stop.
Ditsy, stop right now.
Stop right now, Ditsy.
Your supervisors are here.
Okay, nice.
All right, Ditsy.
Come over here.
This tree.
This tree right here.
Ditsy, get back.
Wow.
Minus points?
Minus points right there.
Yeah, minus points right there.
I feel like we can...
We can...
We can get another shrimp goon here whenever we want, Ditsy.
So prove your worth and pee on this tree right now.
Pee on it.
Right now.
Oh, hey, food.
No, no, no, no.
You can have it.
Nom, nom, nom, nom.
Nice.
All right.
Good job, Ditsy.
That's like a decent form.
Decent form.
But, like, honestly, you have to raise your leg like this.
Okay.
Ditsy, like, remember.
This is how you actually pee on.
Yeah, like this.
That's right.
Show them how it's done.
Yeah.
We're the professionals here.
We started this company.
The shrimp company Welcome to Shrimp Goon Incorporated
Shrimp Gooning Inc
This company was built from nothing Dancing, you're peeing,
you're peeing at nothing You're just marking the empty You
have to pick trees Oh wait, that's my food Oh
Good job Nice tree, nice tree.
7 out of 10, I would say.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
The like needs some work, but otherwise...
You're getting there, Ditsi.
You're getting there.
He's learning.
Om, om, om, om, om, om, om, om, om.
I love our intern, Fang, who keeps feeding us food.
It's like an Uber run.
Fang's like, Uber, it's here.
Uber, it's Uber, it's like one of the boys that brings the
bus like an apple every day.
Yeah, yeah.
Ditsi, why can't you be more like, fight whoa it's uti it's
uti it's uti oh my god they're killing fang you must submit
we gotta see submit submit us we gotta take our puppy we
need to get your book out out help my butt don't worry
there's more of us than them that's right that's right Our
three is bigger than their three.
I got this guy!
Don't worry!
Kill!
Oh!
I like you're just howling while we're trying to kill.
Don't mind me.
Don't mind me, we're just howling.
UTI!
Yeah, UTI!
And then we follow a puppy!
We need to get puppy.
We need to get a female.
We got you.
We need to take her puppy.
Take a puppy.
UTI, get over here.
UTI.
Get over here.
You can't run away forever.
I'm the alpha.
So I was like, don't get UTI.
Don't get a UTI.
That would be bad.
How do I make puppy submit?
Come on, puppy.
Submit.
Join our pack.
Robbie's just running.
Come on, you can't.
Join us.
Show us where your puppies are.
Take our puppies.
Oh, I got him.
I got him.
That's right.
UTI.
No.
No, he's still running.
I got UTI.
Yes.
No, I mean, not actually got UTI, but...
Not actually, but...
like almost look look in the end and any other way chasing
uti it's a puppy's injured yes yes submit submit to us
submit submit my body language i have to be like i have to
be like voice i have to be like uti down uti down uti down
oh my god we have the territory now too Wait, I need to
start peeing.
Okay, okay.
This has to be, like, full yards.
Nice.
Alright.
53%.
Nice.
Bring us to your puppies.
Bring us to your puppy.
Where's the puppy?
Bring us to your puppies.
Where's your puppy?
If you don't bring...
If you want your puppies to live, you bring us to them.
Wait, I thought they were supposed to live.
What do you mean?
I mean, if we kill her before she tells us what the puppies
are, then we'll...
just die come on bring us to your puppies or join our pack
join our pack come on join us no we've reached the edge
she's gonna get away no she actually made it back we got she
has to come back sooner or later she'll come sooner or later
she will watching she will cross past the reverse get away
from us the shrimp goons incorporated shrimp gooning ink
let's go taking puppies since 1999
you'll come back your puppies over you'll be back you'll be
back we can wait forever at the edge Soon or later, you'll
have to leave the edge.
You'll live on territory.
It's expanding.
Oh my god, look at us go.
Let's see.
How many do we need now?
We need three more, three more, guys.
Let's go.
Go forth.
Give us that territory.
We need three more.
Keep peeing.
I see you at the edge.
Go to that blue one.
right now.
All right.
Did I just hear another wolf?
Did you?
Okay.
That was a wolf I can briefly unlike my compass.
Oh, maybe.
Do we see a known wolves?
No, we don't.
Oh my god, they're dead.
Turns like, oh, did you see that?
You could've got a known wolf.
Oh my god, they're just dead.
They're just dead.
Holy shit.
Look, that was on them.
They did that, not us.
They were in our okay they made me do it thing.
I am giving you a new job.
I am delegating go find us Fang you cannot say no to this
you cannot say you by joining the server you've signed the
contract You knew you know what you were getting into you
knew what you were getting into find you knew another den
That is your job.
That is your purpose now go.
We don't need uber eats anymore we're cutting costs we're
cutting it's dead now it's dead now we're delegating the job
go go fang find us more re-homing yeah we don't need look we
spent too much money on uber eats we have to cut down man
yeah it's not cheap yeah uber eats has realized that like
we've been paying like 30% tip each time we gotta cut down
they were like yeah no I don't know if it's profitable yeah
I kind of have to disagree here maybe ordering out every day
was not a great idea Lily maybe we should start cooking
cooking takes time and effort and skill but cooking is like
$10 versus $50 each day somewhere else like what lily like
medical bills or something i don't know like what just fuck
the uti just who cares you can you can do it you can manage
what do you mean our company's gonna go under we don't cut
costs also when you sleep i'm eeppy i'm eppy Me, me, me, me,
me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me,
me, me, me, me, I open my eyes, and I see some wolves being
awake, you're going to be, gonna have a bad bad time i swear
i i we we took this block of time in our schedule for
mandatory company sleep time and you are wasting company's
time right now by not sleeping you have to sleep this is
what we have to cut costs do we do you want me to remove
company sleep time Puppy is back!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, that's her!
Come back, Puppy!
No!
What the fuck?
Why did she like pop up next to us?
She was like, oh, you're nice and vulnerable and lonely.
Why was she there?
She was like, Pinkaboo, Pinkaboo!
You guys wanted to take my puppy!
At this point, she's just flexing, bro.
She's like, oh, you can't catch me.
Oh, you can't catch me.
Here's the edge again.
Oh, you made it always.
Boom.
All right, I'm going to pee more.
We need to pee more.
It's not fully ours, yes.
It has to be fully ours.
It has to be more pee.
More yellow.
We'll pee on the animals.
More pee.
Dang, did you find a den?
Why are you just peeing?
That's not your job.
Your job is to find the house.
Look, peep, performance review is like in two days and it
doesn't look really nice right now.
At this point, the best we can do is give you a nice
reference for your next job.
If you don't find it, then by the end of this day, that
performance review ain't gonna look so good, Vang.
You're gonna have some hold in your resume.
Yeah, you might need to update your resume soon.
I'm just gonna say your ability to be a wolf is not looking
so gay on a scale from one to wolf you're I don't know I
don't know you're more like a fucking dog a domesticated one
not like the good kind of domesticated dog more like a
fucking chihuahua fucking little rat yeah one more we need
one more hex we need one more hexagon and we need three more
caves i'm trying to mark this hexagon now this this cat is
like on my ass go just run just run away i want this
territory i want this to be mine bro what's the cat gonna do
it's a cat that's right but yeah kill him no cats allowed
Nom, nom, nom.
I'm peeing.
I'm going to make this hexagon mine.
You cannot run.
I'm faster.
Okay.
Well, you better be faster.
You fucking invested in speed.
My speed and my spin is taking.
Of Rias!
I knew it was worth it.
Did you kill the cat?
No, but I'm catching up to it.
It tastes like it.
He caught up to the cat.
Come here, kitty.
Kitty, kitty, kitty.
Why do we still only have one home?
Only Dirt found us a home.
I knew Dirt was like the...
I knew hiring Dirt was the right call, Lily.
When I saw that resume, I knew he was getting...
Dirt was going to make...
He would be very valuable to the company.
Yeah, Dirt was going to make Trim Goon Incorporated a rising
star he knows what's up bro someone said someone apparently
there's a dragon and they're like there was in the chat and
he told us he had 200 hours on wolf quest oh my god there is
a gamer he's a knower he's a knower i just joined him we had
a couple of 50 plus hour Andes I knew too.
I knew it Those who joined instantly in wolf quest
anniversary They've they were already playing the game
before They were playing long before we played Dude already
had it like loaded up before the stream even started They
knew They fucking knew Playing being like wait They're
playing my game They're playing my game Let me leave my my
200 hours server real quick let me let me leave my family
real quick I pee do we have 15 hexagons now guys do we do it
we still need one more I killed the cat we need guys dirt
dirt I know I can trust you find us another home dirt
banning doing quite a great job right now
go shadow dirt and learn how to be a real wolf go shadow
dirt learn how to be a good one we're giving you one more
chance shadow the real wolf only this way you will one day
become a real wolf yeah one day you'll be just as good as a
wolf like dirt Fang, we don't need food!
We're all full!
Oh, I'm claiming this.
I'm claiming this so hard.
That's okay.
That's why Fang is just an intern.
Pressure watching it.
Look, Fang, I hate to break it to you, but like, that
college reference, that extra credit, ain't looking so good,
Fang.
You got it.
I don't know about the extra credit anymore.
Fang, you got it.
Fang is feeding me.
Dirt.
Oh, hang on.
I'm feeling dirt right now.
You know what?
That's a good intern.
Intern, show your belly to Fang.
Fang, show your belly to dirt or to me.
Show your belly.
That's right.
Show it.
Or I'm going to growl.
We have 15 out of 15 hexagons.
Oh, we did it.
Let's go.
We did it.
We just need to discover dense.
We just need dents.
All right.
Our main goal, we don't end stream until we have puppies.
That's our goal.
We need the puppies.
That is our...
We have to have...
I will make the 24-hour thing if I have to.
I need puppies.
We must be the worst WolfQuest players out there.
It takes us 24 hours.
I appreciate that.
It does not take 24 hours.
I'm like, it's 48 if I have to.
Dirt, stop hunting.
We need it.
We need a den.
You know, okay, no, that's fine.
Wait, you can eat for yourself?
What about me?
I'm the alpha.
I'm following dirt right now.
Wait, where are you?
I'm at the border.
You're at the border.
We don't need any more hexagons.
I am looking for a den.
All right.
we can make I'm following dirt I need to make sure he is on
track I need to make sure he knows what he's doing I'm his
supervising is to be supervised all the time he's like one
annoying coworker who gets nothing done yeah it's like yep
gonna have to supervise dirt again I'm the supervisor that
gets paid twice as much as dirt we're just watching for only
five percent of the work You show up late you sit around on
your chair watching a bit and now I'm like whoop there we go
Gonna go on my Ferrari now.
Bye guys, you guys didn't get invited to the company dinner
with the CEO Man, that sucks guys That's too bad.
That's too bad.
You got to earn it like me I guess you didn't do it, you
know, it didn't work hard enough this company Maybe next
year.
Oh my gosh.
I got caught upon for the company promotion.
Oh my guys.
Guys, you can be just like me if you work just as hard.
I knew my hard work would pay off.
I knew supervising.
Supervising is a very, is a very hard job guys.
It's so hard.
It's so difficult.
You wouldn't understand.
It's so hard.
Like I have to like watch dirt over here and like I could be
doing.
other stuff right now but instead i have to make sure dirt
does a good job yeah how's what i know of dirt's doing a
good job or if he's half-assing it exactly i'm a valuable
asset to this company by making sure dirt is working
overtime someone was like i'm low-key getting something
because this happened to me i should have happened to all of
us at some point this is what we know it so
I came here for escapism, not be reminded of my wagey life.
Like...
It's so close to home, man.
What the heck?
Yes, we're just wolves, guys.
We're just wolves.
It's just a coincidence that it's like a, it's like a wagey.
So it was like, let me out of my cagey.
I'm angry now.
Weiji let me out of Makiji where where are all the dens how
could there be like even find them how could it be a lack of
dens it's nature right it's fucking nature there should be
holes everywhere give me holes give me holes why can't I
just make a hole like why do I have to look for one just
make one I know we can dig a hole together right just dig
dig dig dig dig where's our dig button there I know you can
be better than this dirt come on it has I know you're
limping and you have a broken leg but this is important you
know come on sometimes you just have to push through yeah
just like me you give us a hundred and fifty percent with
that broken leg right there this company is like a family
which i will remind you when i get your a fight on our pizza
for our meeting pizza party we're our family it's okay we
have pizza though don't worry we have pizza we have pizza
welcome to shrimp goods incorporated don't worry don't worry
your overtime will be paid Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's cold and cheap, but don't learn about it.
The cheese is, like, fully hard on you.
It's like, it's like, we don't even buy it from a pizza
place.
We go to, like, a supermarket for those refrigerated pizzas.
The fucking oven pizzas.
Yeah, yeah, no, and then, but we get, like, a used pizza box
from, like, Domino's, and then put it in.
It's like fresh Domino's pizza.
Fresh Domino's pizza.
This doesn't look like Domino's pizza.
What the heck?
What are you trying to say?
It's in the pizza box.
What do you mean?
I'm saying I'm lying.
What the heck, man?
Are you trying to say your bosses are lying to you?
After everything we did.
After everything we've done.
Yeah, we opened the server for all of you guys.
It's almost like you don't appreciate our hardworking
supervisors.
Look at all these hexes we got for you.
All 15 of them was done from Lily and I.
And all we asked for you was a den.
A home, a place to call home.
We just wanted a place to call home.
And this is how you pay your family.
Yeah.
We took you in, gave you shelter, gave you work.
There, where is...
Oh, wait, it's EP time.
Oh, I found a new dog.
Wait, a new dog?
It's EP time though.
I found two.
Eepie time.
Eepie me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me.
Wait, you guys all spawn in with me.
Wait, what the heck?
What the fuck?
What was that?
That was trippy.
I just...
What?
That's right, that's when you know I'm alpha.
Don't even the snow parted.
Like, what the heck?
Like, what the...
It just went and there you go.
Oh my god, there's all of us.
It'd be cute.
Look at us.
This is so cute.
Oh my god, look at all these wolves.
Look at all these wolf bees.
Oh my god.
It's daytime.
Yippee.
We're next to a den.
Wait, we are?
We are!
Guys, we did it!
What the heck?
We did it!
How do we...
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
We have to kill her.
Okay, guys, come on.
Surround her.
Oh, we have to fight first.
This is our Surround her.
This is our den.
Our puppies will be here.
This is our children now.
This is for our pups only.
Our puppies.
Your bloodline ends here.
How is she still half HP?
There's literally four of us.
Right?
Like, no, she's strong.
Bro, how old is she?
That's not a wolf.
That's a cougar.
She can pack a pond, bro.
Whoa.
That's fucking right.
That's our home now.
Okay, how do we claim this?
Our den.
Piss.
Do we...
Did you...
Piss.
P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P.
Our den now.
All right, Fing.
We need another home.
Fing!
You know, I'm going to splurge a little bit.
Now bring me food.
I'm ordering Uber Eats.
I would like...
One rabbit, please.
Thank you very much.
All right, 10% tip.
How generous.
A whole 10% tip.
A whole 10% tip if you get me that rabbit on Uber Eats.
We need two more.
Two more.
And then we'll have...
Puppers.
Reveal two dens.
Okay, you established and found several.
It's time to give your pack.
It's time to give our pack a name.
How should we name?
Oh, wait a minute.
Shrimp Groons Incorporated.
Let's go.
There you go.
Continue.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
You want to keep working on territory and looking for gems
or proceed to choosing a den?
You know what?
We can choose a den now.
We can choose a den.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Choose a den.
All right.
Remember, you must maintain it even when your pups require
all your time.
The smaller your tank, They're more likely a stranger wolves
will be tempted to come in and kill your pups kill my
puppies hello They can't kill her puppies if we kill them
first Yeah, we'll just we'll just kill them before they kill
us what the hell?
We'll just kill their puppies.
Oh, oh puppy cutscene puppy cutscene Your pups will be born
soon now that the snow is beginning to melt It's time to
find a good den site.
There's no need to dig a new den for yourself since there
are many potential sites any sure we visit the dens you
discovered over the winter oh okay so we just go back to
where we found our dent oh hey oh my rabbit my uber eats is
here nice uber eats nice i got my uber eats thank you fey
cavities underneath all three roots and gaps on the large
boulders okay all right you know it was a good idea for us
to uh open the server I'm taking forever I just think we
would have figured this out on our own I would have also
looked for something way bigger I was like oh then no
problem I'll just look for like a huge massive cave How hard
can it be?
Oh is this a good dent?
This is a wood and the trees providing covered Will limit
the ability for eagles?
The eagles can't eat our puppies?
What the heck?
They don't know how to do that What?
Alright, I'm gonna go with this one The first one I found.
Do you have a cutscene or is it only me?
Wait, I think it's only you.
I'm just running around.
What do we name our den?
I'm coming.
I'll give you the choice of the name.
You don't want to do that.
No, no, it's fine.
I trust in you after your UTI.
I have my full trust on you.
Well, our den should be called infected butthole.
Okay, I'll take one word from this.
mild infection I'll give you infected I'll give you
infected toe clippings okay I'll give you infected I'll give
you I have a feeling you don't like my names very much no I
don't think you like it I like 50% of it I'm like that's
still a pass that's still That's still a pass Right there Um
Um Okay Infected Oh hey Flammable lighter fluids Okay it's
okay Already named her Your dentist ready for post They will
be Yes Go up a bin Wait who's the mom and dad Yeah I placed
that Quest completion dialogues open How's the parents Yeah
how How do I just My toast is We just like Oh Do you see
this this no my screen is just black oh there it is after
nine weeks of gestation five pups are born five bro that's
way too many mouths blind and death oh what what the heck
useless useless how do we put them to work if they're blind
and let's name them oh no oh no can you For three weeks,
you, they first emerged from Zen into sunlight.
They all dark brown, but a few weeks their pubs' coats would
change.
Is that me?
Am I...
I thought I was male.
I'm a male too, made by my mind.
I'm also male.
All right.
I'll name one of them a dragon.
I'll get that.
Yeah, yeah.
Lock that in.
All right.
Wait, oh, wait.
Oh, each of us gets to name one.
Wait, are you guys naming?
Okay, okay.
Wait, we each, all of us, made puppies to get...
We don't know who the mom and dad is.
Oh, shit, it's one puppy each.
We know who the mom is.
We don't know who the dads are.
We each get one.
Guys, no, my puppy will not be eagled.
I swear.
the puppy okay now four weeks so your pups are too big for
the den as they spend their day playing to increase the
affinity of your fam plaque if they're playful play with
their hungry feed them if they stray far from the then go
find them and carry them back pups mostly eat meat
regurgitated by the adults in your pack okay that's your job
lily my wife you can you can do that
I can't wait to do that.
Someone named their puppy.
Dirt named their puppy Dirt Junior.
That's my puppy.
Where's your puppy?
Dirt Junior is so cute.
I think my puppy died.
Wait, what?
Wait, Aqua.
Okay, I'm pretty sure the fifth puppy has to be yours if
they're...
These guys, I'm pretty sure.
Thank you.
Where's my puppy?
Is the name not good enough?
Did I die?
Where's the...
No!
Okay.
Look, I'll be sweet here and name the track Would you
fucking name your shrimp puppy constipation?
Shrimps, remember which streamer actually Remember who
cares?
Remember who fucking cares Like, come on Oh my god Chad, you
like the name, right?
Type one if you like my name, come on Type one if you're a
pre- I appreciate my name.
That's my streamer.
I love how your puppy is the last one to come out too.
Yeah, I mean, he looks up to his name.
He looks up to his name.
He knows what's up.
Wait, there's a fox!
Oh my god, there's danger!
Oh, fox, fox, fox!
That's a fox!
There's a fox!
She's trying to eat her baby!
Put him in!
Get him!
Take constipation, but not the trickle woman!
Don't take constipation!
Stop!
Don't take it!
No!
He's going closer!
Oh my god, he ran away!
He ran away, he ran away, he can't take it!
That's right, that's right, get the hike away.
That's right.
Your pups are safe again for a moment.
Alright.
Constipation, you may stop clenching your butt cheeks.
It's important.
One more and later, why?
I still can't believe it was the last one to come out.
I still can't believe it.
I'm making a curse.
I chose my name wisely.
Dragoon, look at me, I'm playing with you.
Dragoon.
Play with your fucking puppy.
Look, tail up.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
I'm sick.
Yay!
Look at that.
It's so cute.
What the heck?
It's so beautiful.
You're beautiful.
We're proud.
Everything away.
And I can't breathe either.
We worked so hard, Lily.
This is what we've been working for since we started this
company.
It's totally...
It's paying off.
Oh my god.
It's all over.
Doki, it's all us!
All us!
Oh!
I knew working overtime day and night and Trip Goons
Incorporated won't pay off!
Yippee!
Yay!
Someone in chat just says, you are like my aunts when they
heavily drink.
I don't know if it's a compliment or not, but thank you,
thank you.
Oh my god, there's a puppy cam.
You press shift and F.
You'll get to be the puppy.
Shift F.
Oh, puppy cam.
Puppy cam.
That's you guys.
So cute.
Drago, get away from Aqua.
Get away from Aqua.
If you're associating with anybody, it's dirt junior dirt
junior knows what's up he's the 200 hour wolf quest bro i
want you patient do be walking okay get away from
constipation dragoon get away that one's special what's
wrong with constipation oh we got the constipation camera
yeah dragoon when you when you grow up you will be alpha
You will be the new Alpha.
You will be the new Alpha Dragoon.
You will grow up to be a constipation's boss.
No poop breaks until 5.
I can't do that.
I'm glad we opened the server.
I definitely think we would never figure this out.
Oh, we would have never.
We would never figure it.
We would have, we would have, like, had such a hard time.
This is, this is, oh shit.
Thank God.
Thank God the gamers are here to save the day while we
supervise.
Thank God.
Wait, we can pick up our kids?
How do we pick up our kids?
If you hold space on them.
Oh my God.
Get over here, Dragoon.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Stay away from that boy.
He ain't he ain't right.
Oh my god my tail's so ugly like little rat tail I'm just
wagging Look like cats They look like cats.
They don't even look like wolves.
Oh fang you got off your head.
It's so ugly Fine no Come back our uber eats what will we do
about uber eats?
Who would feed them?
Who would feed our puppies combined?
Who would feed the children?
We're supervisors, not doers.
We have worked enough in our lives.
Someone else has the...
Oh!
No!
Protect the babies!
Where is it?
Oh my god, there's four!
There's five of them!
What?
Get the hell?
They're back to our babies!
I got one of them!
Oh no no!
Vane come back!
There's a wag!
Vane!
We need you!
Ah!
Oh my god!
See away!
Not the dragon wand!
Stop!
No!
It's okay!
Children!
Oh no!
Get the fuck away from the babies!
Get away from the babies!
Shoot!
Go!
Leave!
They're in the den, they're in the den, they're safe!
In the den!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I like how fans just sit lying down.
Like, fans just...
They're just chilling.
They want there's a fucking war going out.
He's like, yeah, that's alright.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, don't worry about it.
It's okay, don't worry about it.
There's so many!
Yeah, I'm here, run!
Run!
That is right.
They give it up.
Nice.
You did it, guys.
with us yeah that's right that's right come out little
little babies come out come out come out come constipation
on come on dragon else you're gonna have riots thank you
yeah hello yes dragons you guys live for another day
it's so fucking cute when do they grow up when are you grow
up like right now
I'm new to this.
It just happened.
It's fatherly instinct.
Oh no, my instinct.
My fatherly instinct.
What the heck?
How do I... Where is regurgitating?
food, huh?
I don't know.
It just happened.
I don't even know.
I can rest my chin.
How do I do that?
It just...
Oh, it happened again!
It's just happening.
It just keeps happening.
It doesn't stop.
It might just uncontrollably puke over and over.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
Dang it.
You're not supposed to see that.
I hope that wasn't my job oh my god why don't you feed the
children sad skin i don't have anything to throw up i don't
know how do i throw up just press space space bar i'm so
proud of you i'm so proud of you so gross you're now a
father come here eat my vomit come on children Don't touch
that, Dragoon!
Dragoon, no!
Uh-uh, constipation, don't wander off so far.
Someone's gotta kick Fang out.
He's just chilling, he's like, nope.
Fang is just there.
Fang, you're not even in here anymore.
What are you doing?
Yes, they're eating it!
raining oh god it's raining oh no don't get sick wait we
have fleas i'm a six percent we have fleas wait i don't get
rid of fleas ill oh no we have fleas okay our pups have to
roll around they have to be 15 okay wait how many pounds do
they have to be 15 pounds who's who's underweight Who's
underweight right now?
Wait, Dirt Jr. is not, is like, starving.
Who's not feeding Dirt Jr?
Wait, just eat the vomit, Dirt Jr. Dirt Jr. Eat!
What do I see?
The puppy info?
Oh, pack info?
Yeah, it's pack info.
I can't believe it to be 15 pounds.
You're only 5 pounds.
Dude, they're, like, not growing at all.
What do you mean?
Oh, my God.
Eat.
Okay, I'm gonna eat too so I can feed the puppies Each each
puppy has a favorite wolf that they like to socialize with
more often and I'm not on anyone's list Not even your own
child.
I am I am.
Oh shit.
Okay.
I'm gonna say as your own child I like how dirt claimed two
of them.
There's just like yeah, I'm getting both of them I can't
believe it All right Okay, eat.
Eat.
Dragoon, why are you sleeping?
Dragoon.
Dragoon, socialize with me.
Socialize.
Socialize with me now.
Come on, play with me.
Wee, play with me.
Take a break from socializing with your pups.
Why would I do that?
Wait, wait, what the fuck?
What?
Donkey Lily Love Child.
Who is this?
They peed out my kid.
what wow they peed on my child what the heck that's fucked
up they peed on my child you can't do that don't you you're
so gross what the heck that's fucked up this person beat on
my child bro their bio is puppy and bio the bio is what
their bio is puppy and bio what the heck happened it's just
because fang got kicked down this person's this they're not
waiting this whole time to do this okay whole time all right
Tokyo Lily love child go and go and adopt Fang's child and
rename them you rename them they're your kids now yeah you
can have it you can have that child go rename your kid I
don't know which one I don't know she was she was a wise
name yeah choosing i don't know if it's ivy or aqua i don't
know whose child it is but you'll figure it out you got this
dragon look at me take a break i don't want to take a break
from socializing with my child my child has to be like
socially aware of what's going on i don't want i don't want
him to be anti-social please socialize come on come don't be
a freak dragon i need you to be well adjusted to society all
right oh okay can somebody feed the children i don't have
enough food in my stomach to regurgitate i need someone feed
the kids i need someone to feed the kids can someone just do
yeah guys stop howling we need you to feed the children can
i throw up some more wait evie's gonna die for lack of sleep
okay we gotta sleep we have to sleep okay yeah we gotta
sleep sleep it's sleeping time guys it's okay the kids will
be fine and we all just sleep right they won't get abducted
they won't get abducted while we're all just sleeping around
Yeah, the ego just comes in and takes it away.
Just loops one.
Are we just sleeping?
Don't worry.
I sleep.
Mother, what have you for saying to me?
The ego.
Mother.
Father, help.
Please.
Father, please.
There's an ego.
Wake up!
wake up please wake up who is that wolf behind us that's not
sleeping is that dokylilly lovechild puppy and bio if he is
that we have to we have investigating investigating sleep
we're sleeping the alpha request sleep excuse me sir could
you please lay down sleep thank you thank you Oh no, it'd be
so fucked up an ego just swoops in right now.
I'm looking at the children.
Where's Dragoon?
Dragoon?
Wait, he actually got eaten by an eagle.
Oh, there's Dragoon!
Oh, there he is!
Okay, they're sleeping.
Oh, thank God.
How did you get inside?
They're inside?
I just pressed Spacebar.
Oh.
You can see the kids.
Oh, that's so cute.
What the?
Oh, so cute.
all right let's see we need all right they are seven pounds
they're halfway there guys feed we need a hunt all right we
got honey we need a little our can regurgitate yeah we have
to hunt okay yeah yeah all right let's hunt that's hunt okay
i'm looking i'm i'm in scent mode now okay okay i'm sniffing
follow me follow me follow me you're picking something up
i'm picking somebody up okay i went the wrong way i'm behind
you i went the wrong way Walking the wrong way with you?
It's this way?
You got this?
Follow me, follow me!
I know exactly where I'm going!
But that's the wrong donkey!
I found the wrong donkey!
Are you following the donkey, Lily, love child?
Yeah, that's like way in!
Wrong donkey!
It's okay, I'm picking up the scent!
Where are you?
Where are you, little rabbit?
Oh my god, where's the rabbit?
Where the fuck did the rabbit go?
I can't find the rabbit!
There!
I see, I see elk.
I see a wolf!
I can't eat the wolf!
Wait, there's elk here!
There's elk here!
Elk?
Oh, shit, we can have an elk.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a lot of food that we can, that we can, like, feed
the children.
Oh, we can't, we can't puke so much.
We can't have so much bomb.
I'm going up.
I'm getting up there.
You're so fast.
Why did I not have that?
number nine speed why didn't i invest in speed should i run
with speed it was a mistake they're too fast oh my god i
swear it's gonna take me like 20 years to get to these deers
they're so quick i'm going so fast they're not i'll run them
eventually we just have to outlast true that's true that's
true there's no way these deers can can run forever yeah you
have like stamina investment you got this you got there's no
way i hope somebody's protecting the cubs while we're gone i
hope we've come back no cubs at all i i hope i hope the kids
are okay Please be okay.
Please be okay.
We're hunted.
That, like, somebody's, like, spamming eagles.
I gave up.
They are two.
Kaka!
Oh, there's a...
Freedom Eagles.
Freedom.
Welcome to America.
This is America.
Oh, my God.
I'm catching up.
There's a bear!
No!
Somebody say no!
Kids!
Guys, there's a bear on their kids!
What the heck?
Is there anybody near?
Oh, they're back.
There's people near.
It's okay.
We've had our babysitters right there to burn off the bear.
We're coming back, children.
Oh, my God.
There's a bear.
I'm so far from home.
Okay, wait, wait.
There's like, I got food, though.
I'm going to eat real fast.
I want children undying, however.
However, daddy's hungry.
Okay.
Sorry, daddy's a little hungry right now.
Just a little hungry.
Oh, oh, they did it!
They did it!
They fended off the bear!
Oh, oh my god.
I knew.
I knew the shrimp goons could do it.
Dude, we were so far away from there.
Yeah, we did.
Those kids were fucking dead.
We're so far away.
Yeah, thank God for the shrimp goons because definitely our
kids would have been gone.
Dude, can you imagine all this?
work just for them to be gone because we killed freaking
deer we didn't even get the deer that's the worst part i was
so close wait i'm sniffing something oh send me something
all right yeah i'm just gonna hope that like fucking food
comes out food just jumps into your mouth yeah yeah i'm just
hoping like somebody just wants to you know they just don't
wait wait i found a herd i found a herd wait i don't think
i'm far from you Oh, wait.
I am rather fine.
It's okay.
I found an elk.
I'm on my way.
I found a herd of deer.
Oh, my God.
Your kids are going to eat so well.
Oh.
On my way.
No, not this way.
Okay, fuck it.
Get deer faster.
Four kids.
Okay.
Okay, I'm getting him.
He's like half HP.
Oh, no.
He's so far.
Oh, I think I see you from like the distance.
Holy shit.
Wait, I actually see you.
me no way what from the distance I saw something like run
down the hill my jaw I broke my jaw I need you to tag out I
need you to tag out with me I broke my jaw I'm so far still
are you still so far okay it's a it's a really big deer all
right don't worry He's almost dead.
We gotta bring this food over.
Come on, my way.
We gotta bring the food over.
Okay.
I got him!
Yo, let's go!
Let's go, let's go.
Let's feed the children.
Okay, I'm gonna go eat this real fast.
We have to eat a lot.
Yeah, we have to eat a lot.
Sat's gay.
Come over here.
Eat your elk.
I'm coming.
You gotta be full.
whoop do not i swear to do not pee on this deer i swear to
god i would never i swear to god i would i would never what
the heck i would never i don't know i do not trust you right
now don't worry children papa's got some food in the stomach
don't worry dragon okay i think i will feed Okay, I can eat
more.
Oh, shit, let's go.
Yeah, keep eating until you're full.
Okay, I'm full.
I'll take a piece of meat.
Yo, I got a big piece.
Let's go.
Take it to feed the rest of the pack.
Yeah.
It's nice that you actually cared about, like, the rest of
the pack because I just get full and just wouldn't.
I was like, I'm full now.
Let me go over.
Adios.
I did my job Feeding myself Someone had to do it These
interns ate shit They saved our children But come on man
Children Papa's here I swear to God If the kids don't If you
socialize with my kid too much I swear to God They're
stealing our children The bed It's very good Who the fuck
Need the chill child is a better dragon.
Wait, there's fucking...
Wait, what the heck?
Wait, I haven't fed the kids yet!
I'm trying to feed.
Oh, there we go.
No, don't go back to the game!
Dude, I got attacked.
Where's the...
Where is it?
Where?
From where?
Oh, I see them.
I see them.
But right behind me.
Okay, you guys.
You guys go protect.
I'm just gonna give them more food.
That's right.
Oh, they already gave up.
That was fast.
Wow, we did it.
Wow.
Wow, we're so good at this.
Wow, we're so good at this game.
What the heck?
Yeah, alright.
Come out.
Come out and eat.
Eat.
Come here, constipation.
I have some fresh warm for you.
Beautiful,
beautiful.
Oh my god.
Oh,
better dragon goodness like the cool that's like 8.6 pounds.
What were you doing?
Wait, what's the rest of them mine's eight pounds.
So like he's okay.
Wait, he's He's growing big how what the hell?
Wait, how what's yours yours is 7.9 on your someone's not
taking care of the kids I might have to call will support
He's constipated.
Okay, I'm gonna call will support on you seven point.
That's mount nourishment right there don't call wolf support
please i'm gonna call wolf support good luck with
don't take him with my constipation please
i love it so much ma'am how many times are you feeding your
children like at least two at least What is that in a
two-way two-way just just two
Don't worry.
It's just it's just the kids don't need sleep.
They need food They don't need sleep We just need to feed
just Dirk junior.
What is this?
I'm gonna put you good job.
Yes, it would be a shame Dirk junior Wait, actually no not
Dirk junior.
I need a fine.
Where's the better trip?
There's better Dragoon.
It would be a shame if something happened to you.
It would be a shame if something happened.
It would be a shame if someone wouldn't find back home.
Oh Dragoon, you're doing great.
Oh no, where did Bada Dragoon go?
Bada Dragoon go!
It would be such a shame if something happened to that
child.
Oh look at them eeping!
They're so cute!
Look at them!
They're eeping!
Look at them, num.
Alright, let's see.
How full are they?
Constipation is tired!
He's eepy!
Let him sleep!
He wants to eat!
He's eeping.
Where are you?
He's...
Go eep!
No!
He has 8% sleep right now.
See?
He's sleeping now.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
This is going to take forever.
Why aren't you not adults yet?
What the heck?
Why aren't you adults in within like 10 minutes?
What the fuck?
Grow.
Just grow.
Just grow, man.
Grow.
Oh, we got to sleep too.
time me me time me me me me guys other oh they're walking
away guys if we all eat they won't walk far what makes you
say that if we eat when we wake up they're just they're just
gone it's okay less mouse to feed if you think about it it's
called survival of the fittest okay it's survival of for
exactly man it's okay eagles who's not eating the the sky's
not moving who is not eating right now the sky isn't moving
help i need more sky we need the sky has to move who is not
eating who did not press z and only pressed r who is it guys
guys i'm gonna look at your eyes right now oh my god close
that rabbit's so fucking best we're we're sky why is it
still nighttime oh there it is what the what the wait what
the what is that what what happened what happened what
what's going on wait oh that eagle stealing eagle kaka kaka
did we have dreams your pups are going bigger the center den
while you are away as long as you pack affinity is high oh
please please get them away get out where's the flea control
how do we stop this it's okay let me stop please just like i
don't know how do we stop please can i just like roll around
in the dirt and like stop the fleas.
What's the callers for if we can't stop the fleas?
Don't worry, I got food for you guys.
Breakfast time!
Here you go, it's breaky time!
It's breaky time!
Alright, Dragoon.
Let me... It's time to make sure you're socialized for the
world.
I need you to be well-adjusted wolves.
Nice.
Alright.
Look at us go.
I'm so proud of our baby.
I don't want to take breaks from what Pissed on the pump I
don't think so Why are you not 15 pounds yet Stop pissing on
the puffinies
Stop pissing on the puffinies Stop that's my puppy We just
cause the patient Where is he?
No, no, no.
That's okay right.
I'll do it on your food too.
No, no, the food.
That's right.
He's eating the food.
He's eating the pee-pee food.
That's right.
That's what you...
No!
Why did she do it yourself?
Wait, oh, fuck.
That's on you.
Oh my God.
That's right.
You gotta be extra socialized.
Dude, constipation is past the fuck out.
I need not sleep.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, they're 10 pounds now!
Oh my god!
They're 10 pounds.
We just need five more pounds.
We need a hunt.
They're so close.
All right, we call this when they're 15 pounds, and then we
call it.
Yeah, yeah.
We got...
So they're more independent, so we don't have to come back
so they can fend for themselves.
So they can fuck off.
Yeah, yeah, we kick them out.
start your own life but they're 18 now so you cannot
reloaders there's a plane in the sky oh my god there's a
flying thing all right it's yellow like you like me take it
down so take it down i can only be one there can only be one
yellow what the heck who allowed them to be yellow we gotta
make sure they're 15 pounds or they'll have to pay rent oh
my god you're still living at home bison yeah there's bison
near me oh my god oh my god they just oh i'm oh okay bison
too scary i can't i can't bison is too strong we will get
the bison we're getting invaded we are coogers oh coogers oh
i'm limping okay bison is i have a fractured lake right now
so unlucky.
I think I'm gonna be reduced to child care.
I can't hunt anymore.
I'm gonna be a stay-at-home father.
I realize hunting, just hunting wasn't for me.
Oh my god, where's the cougars?
No, they're in the den.
Okay, we have to find a new house for them too.
Because like they're now, they're just gonna be filled with
fleas now.
Oh!
No!
We have a couple we have other dens though, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have to move to a new den Go places.
Okay after we kill this cougar.
Where the fuck is the cougar?
Where is it?
Oh, he's right here.
It's right here.
I'm helping But I'm supervising.
I have a broken leg.
I'm supervising I'm supervising I'm supervising.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, doing.
Yeah, you guys are doing great.
Good job.
Good job guys.
Okay Make sure to grab the neck, you know?
Grab the neck and fit tighter.
It's all in the neck.
Then we go neck tie him.
Nice, nice, nice.
Now bring him down.
Now, if you do a flip, you're going to flip him to the back.
Okay, guys?
Flip it on his back.
Do it.
Dude, he's tanky.
What the heck?
Bro, he's so tanky.
It's a cat.
M.C., what are you doing?
You're not supervisor.
you're not supervising what the heck yeah what are you doing
that's right now go now bite the leg here on the the hind
leg yeah yeah one hind leg one leg oh there you go good job
guys good job that's what i call a team he peed on the
cougar real quick just mark our territory so i know i have
to know all right i'm gonna move the puffs to a new den
because there's too many fleas all right oh many fleas okay
puppies 41 fleas what the heck okay yeah we're moving these
puppies we are moving these puppies yeah these puppies need
to get out wait where is my house okay why don't we move all
right into the middle i guess the center of our territory
all right Move to a... Do you want moved?
Yes.
Okay.
You're off to a new den.
Continue.
You go hunting between...
Finding patch of tall grass.
Okay.
We each pick up our child.
Pick up our child.
I've got my child.
No pee on my child!
Alright.
Okay.
We're gonna go downwards, guys.
Actually, no, up.
Up is faster.
We're gonna go up here.
Follow me.
Follow your alpha.
Following the leader?
Where am I?
Give me a sec.
I need to figure out where I am first.
So this is West?
I don't know where I'm...
Which one's me?
Is this me?
Am I the red?
Yeah, I'm the red.
Don't worry, guys.
Follow the alpha.
Come on, she's got this.
I got this.
Yes, okay, we go straight.
We go straight.
She got a plan.
Pick up your child and go straight.
I hope we're not missing a child.
I hope for.
Can you imagine we like forgot one?
All these bear attacks, cool girl, right?
It's, and we just forget it at the mall.
Yeah, we forgot one kid at the mall.
We're like, we got everybody, right?
It's everybody here.
If the yellow wolf could pick up that child, uh, Dragoon,
yes.
Guys, I'm limping.
Give me a sec.
I can't run anymore.
I have to walk now.
Just walk for half.
Wait, where did my child go?
Oh my god.
He's digging.
Why are you digging?
Digging for tragic.
All right, here you go.
Dragoon, it's not time for fun right now.
You're filled with fleas.
You can't go to school.
You're nasty.
You got fleas.
Oh my god, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
Follow the alpha.
So close.
It's up close.
This is like, Jason.
Jason.
Jason Jason Oh my god I don't know More stamina What the
heck You have to drop your child Drop the baby I don't want
to drop the No constipation Stop Come here Drop the baby No
constipation Stop it Oh Where's the Where's the Turner He's
a fleeting one Is this the Turner Oh there it is This is
This is okay This is a pretty shitty den but uh it's fine oh
we got food right here all right we can just put them here
yeah hunt all right here we go welcome my new oh the sauce
all right what do we call this house really i'll take 50 of
your name 50 i was starting to believe you just don't
appreciate my I give you 50%!
I take 50, you take 50, it's just fair!
Okay, okay.
Moist.
Okay, 50% of that is...
No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, how it works.
You give me a name and I take 50% of it.
That's exactly how it works.
Moist, moist cabbage dent.
Okay, cabbage.
Yes, yes, yes.
mold is fun fungus it's too late damn it i already need your
new home guys what's our new home called yeah i'm gonna go
find food cabbage good i'm gonna grab us some food I just
hunted something down.
All right, I'm going to eat this real fast.
It's a small little antelope.
All right, nice.
Holy shit, this guy is zooming.
Okay, I'm going to eat this rabbit.
Nice.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Vom, vom, vom, vom.
All right, how much do they weigh now?
They are 10.5.
Okay, 11.
Someone, what are those 11 pounds right now?
One that's malnourished.
Who the fuck is not taking care of their children?
Why?
Who the heck is malnourished?
Dixie, your child is malnourished.
Feed your child.
Feed.
Feed the baby.
I can't believe it.
Don't make us call a wolf support on you.
I'm coming to Vom.
I'm trying to find more food for us.
Okay.
I'm looking.
Holy shit, it's so hard to find food.
camp who chose this who chose this house there's no food
around us yeah what the heck what the fuck chun did see is
it was it you i bet it was did see let's see how why did you
choose this place there's barely any food anywhere here's
some food all right i got some hair then and then we can
warm all right so hunting with bruised jaw and a broken leg
look look This is...
Parenthood is hard.
It's difficult, okay?
It's difficult.
You think you can hunt an elk on your own?
That's fucking right.
Ow!
No constipation!
Stop sleeping!
He's hungry!
I mean, he's sleepy!
Look at his...
He has 7% sleep!
What do you mean?
Why is he never sleeping?
I mean he's actually EEPI.
I mean don't fucking sleep.
Your fucking...
Your fucking child is actually sleep deprived.
Why is he always EEPI?
He's playing too much video games.
I can't believe it.
I told you!
I told you making him play video games is a bad idea.
He should...
But someone has to farm gold.
Yes!
What's the point of raising offspring if they can't be gold
farmers?
Until your in-game chores.
Oh my god, there's so many walls on me!
Oh my god!
Guys!
I'm funny!
I'm dead!
Someone help me!
I got ambushed!
Wait, how far?
Wait, how far are you?
What the heck?
I got ambushed!
Oh my god!
Wait, my god!
Oh!
Holy shit!
What the heck?
Someone revive me!
Ow!
Leave it up!
I got jumped!
I'm so dead!
What the heck?
I got jumped!
No!
They can distract him!
Distract him!
I'm gonna live!
I'm gonna...
No!
These got me!
Stop!
I'm running away I'm running away she's I'm dead again No!
No, I'm so dead!
I'm so dead!
Ah, there's too many of them!
There's too many!
Help!
No, I got distracted!
No!
Oh yeah, they got jumped I went to the wrong part of town!
Leap away!
Holy shit!
I'm ready.
Oh my god.
I accidentally invaded somebody else's territory.
I learned my lesson.
I'm sorry.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I'm so fucked up right now.
Dude, I'm almost dead.
Oh shit.
My leg.
Where am I?
Where's the children?
I need to sleep.
I need...
I'm EP.
I need an EP.
EP time.
Good night, everybody.
Wait, what are children?
Are they inside?
Oh, okay.
They're all inside.
Me, me, me, me, me, me.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
You're telling me to lose Blubber to run faster?
No, the Blubber is what saved me.
I had cushioning.
The extra armor fat.
Yeah.
Why is the fire in the forest?
Guys, don't go to the purple area.
It's dangerous.
Do not the purple.
The purple area.
Never go to purple.
Alright.
How much do they weigh now?
12.3.
Oh, there's 13.
We need two more pounds.
Guys.
Easy.
Two more pounds.
I can't.
I killed something.
It's spoiled probably.
I'm going to go hunt again.
Hunting die.
It's time to hunt.
I need to make sure I don't go to purple.
But my leg is broken.
I don't think I can hunt anything.
Look, I hunted with a broken jaw.
If I can do it, so can you.
Yeah.
Don't be a fucking coward.
Don't be a baby.
Don't be a baby, baby.
Our children need food.
Do you want them to starve after everything we've been
through?
I would never.
Newborn have given birth to...
What?
Oh, oh, I can kill like baby deer.
Ooh.
Oh, killing babies.
Yeah.
Look, it's all about killing the baby so that our babies can
survive.
Okay.
The rabbit.
Nice.
still like so hungry that's right that's right oh oh it dies
fast it's just a baby it dies so fast nice that's what we
got this that's what we got this yeah you got this i believe
in you okay that is a elk whoo okay don't worry i might
bruise my my mouth again oh Fuck!
Okay, never mind.
You... The elk won.
The elk won.
Oh, God.
I'm not that strong.
I'm just...
I'm so weak.
That's okay.
It's okay.
We don't need that.
Oh, there's a car...
The moose?
A deer?
Territorial marking.
done are you feeding the children yeah i'm going back now
i'm gonna run some i'm just gonna eat i'll just i'll just go
with the little ones oh wait that's a fox i don't care about
the fox i can't eat the fox hunt in the pack no those are
for suckers we get four kills what the heck yeah why get one
kill we can get four kill Yeah, we don't give a fuck about
Teamwork.
Come on, children.
It's warm time.
Who needs teamwork?
This is individualism country.
Welcome to America.
We are free to do our own hunting.
We're all special individually.
We're all special individuals.
think of it as a team that is for pussy yeah what the heck
yeah what the fuck teamwork yeah disgusting yeah so fucking
disgusting this is solo queue this is the solo queue
experience wait there's a children I made many warm piles a
pack take down larger prey more food for all if a wolf
cannot take a larger prey then they if a single wolf can't
do it then they're worthless to the path they don't belong
to the path yeah they don't belong banish them they should
each individually be able to take down a giant animal then
storm You starve.
Like I said, he's the Canadian and the German.
We're American at heart.
You won't understand.
You don't understand.
We're American at heart.
Let us be.
You just don't understand.
It's supposed to be the country of freedom.
I'm free to identify as American.
Yeah, exactly.
Fucking preach it, sister.
Preach.
Oh, wait, that's a fox.
I don't care about fox.
Where are you?
Oh, my God.
I can kill a bear.
Baby bear.
Oh, God.
There's baby.
There's a baby bear.
But there's a mama bear.
I want to eat the bear, though.
Just kill the baby real quick and then run away from mama
bear.
Okay.
You won't know him.
Can I please eat this?
Okay, nice.
Dory Jr. found the steak.
I could eat the deer carcass.
It's okay, I found the food.
Don't worry, I got more food for the children.
Yippee!
I'm gonna finish this food.
Okay, I'm coming back.
Do not worry, Dragon.
Do you miss...
I know you...
You haven't seen me in 20 years, but don't worry.
I'm coming back.
Don't worry.
I'm coming back with more food.
Child.
Papa's coming back, child.
Please don't forget my face.
Are they running too far off?
Wait, is this still far from home?
Wait, where are you?
At home.
Okay.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to feed them.
Oh, I'm gonna eat this food.
real fast how do i feed them just to eat the vomit how do i
feed you just to eat the vomit how do i fucking feed no i
don't want i'm gonna fuck up a constipation there's it's a
very serious topic okay wait oh my god we're getting invaded
invaded invaded i'll be in the cave i'll be the cave
Oh, I see him.
I see him Put up Constipation, go in Die Are you fighting
him?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got this Easy.
Oh my god.
Good job.
I'm going to supervise.
Good job, guys.
They're doing great.
Don't let him run.
Yeah!
Nice.
All right.
See?
Perfect.
I'm so proud of you.
no witnesses i'm so proud of us i
have a full belly i want to feed you oh there you go okay i
fed wait where's dragon dragon why are you over there what
the fuck put you there get over dragon let's go home yes go
inside go eeb time you have lots of growing to do eeb time
okay go eat i'm eat see they have full stomachs yes oh my
goodness they're almost done we're doing with my child
where's your child what are you doing my child let him down
let go of my child or i swear better dragon's gonna get it
my child better dragoon's gonna get it right now better
dragoon's gonna get it so hard say goodbye to your child all
right eat are you guys 15 pounds good thing we have food at
home they're 13 pounds you're so close we need two more
pounds come on eat eat don't poop and you will get those
pounds quickly hurry up we need you to eat we've been at
this for three hours why he's still so small how dare you
don't grow to an adult in within three hours what the fuck
yeah what the fuck is wrong with push Dragoon oh there he is
that's like all right eat Dragoon eat eat yeah it's
constipation good boy okay I have to eat it's EP time too no
Wait, I have to do One more plane time Guys, it's EP time EP
time I lost Dragoon, I hope he's okay
Where's Dragoon?
No one knows
I don't like this Dragoon is like walking further
It's like goodbye mother Thank you for nourishing me I was
very concerned
Oh hey look The loading screen Yippee I don't have one this
time Oh I have it My dragon is becoming too independent I
don't like it No it's running off No you're not supposed My
dragon has become ill!
Why are you sick?
Sick, puppy!
Who made you sick?
There's an eagle!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait!
What do we do?
Go inside!
Go home, home, home, home!
Go home, home!
Go into the dead!
Go in!
Oh my god, oh my god, he's okay.
Concentration, please!
No!
Please, go inside!
Concentration, please!
Oh my god, the ego's coming down!
No!
Go here!
He's looking!
He's looking at the children!
Oh, he's flying away, he's flying away!
I picked up constipation, is that enough?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There it is.
It's fine!
Oh, fuck.
They're flying around!
I'm so scared!
I want to pull it out.
I'm scared.
Come away.
I'm going to eat my food.
Oh, it gave up.
It gave up.
See, even though my dragon is sick right now, at least he's
not stupid.
He isn't that stupid.
He knew.
He knew when to hide.
Good job, dragon.
You might be sick right now.
But at least you know when to go inside.
That's my child.
Food to love.
Don't cause the patient just ran away.
Like, what?
You just panic and sprinted.
Like, what was that for?
Guys.
Aqua.
Dixie, your fucking puppy is so malnourished.
Everybody else is fourth almost 15 pounds.
Yours is still 15.
Feed your fucking.
Feed your child.
Go away from my foot.
my food leave it go dragon you're socialized you're
socialized enough that you know when to hide in the cave
when there's an eagle unlike some children unlike some
children I wonder whose child just sprinted away food food
food food food food food oh my goodness look my child he's
just his immune system isn't as good as the others it's not
his fault it's just genetics, okay?
Poor genetics.
And just pass on somebody should use genetics.
What can I say?
It's his most fault.
I'm a strong genetic wolf.
It's not my fault.
I blame the mother.
I blame whoever is the mother.
My genes gave him the best possible genes.
He's tired.
Let's go.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
No, no, no, no, no, no, I need to eat too.
Um, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no,
let's see.
Mine needs 0.5 more pounds.
And then he's...
Bene Dragon!
Who...
Bene Dragon needs to stop eating.
He's going to get too plump.
You two plums!
How is...
Maybe our children got switched and like, but I'd recommend
actually my child because I'm a plumb little boy.
You gotta stop overfeeding your kid!
Doki Lily Love Child!
You gotta stop overfeeding him!
Let the other pups grow!
Yeah, you're denying of a growth.
Yeah, exactly.
This is why my dragon is ill.
Bro, this is why your puppy's a beast.
This is why you need a fucking...
I'm not shaving the puppy.
Bro, he's like two pounds heavier than all the other
puppies.
It's not the average weight of a puppy.
Jesus.
Bro, we need to put that puppy on a treadmill.
A treadmill.
Bro, that puppy needs to be healthy it's a baby fat he's
just fluffy it's just fluffy it's just a baby fat talking
about draconne why are you please socialize with the other
puppies what are you doing why are you away from them
socialize no i shall i shall follow the footsteps of sasuke
draconne's please i trained you better to be social why are
you a loner understand mother you wouldn't get me you don't
understand mother you would just like the other parents stop
walking away play with these children you all grew up
together he's turning into a gamer social distancing because
of sickness
I didn't want you to become like me dragon.
I tried everything I wanted to raise you right And for one I
like how I love how like he's also like um, he's like emo as
fuck because he's like the only puppy that's like a black
puppy.
So he's super emo right now talk to me it's not a face mom
it's not a face mom oh my god mom you're embarrassing me oh
my god time to leave soon almost all your pups have grown 15
pounds very soon be time to leave the den and travel to your
summertime home base called a rendezvous site start planning
your trip by opening a world map which now shows then feed
your pups to get the smallest one over 15 pounds yeah that's
really far that is um distance that's that's pretty far wait
no there's one really close by that's yeah yeah yeah we can
take them there right yeah easily that's not that far yeah
yeah you know we'll call it when we take it to the random
side it's not that far yeah just one little warm and then
like what's the goal Friends are over here.
Please, Dragoon, stop.
Bro, my puppy doesn't even look like a fucking puppy.
He looks like a cat.
He actually looks...
He looks like a fucking cat.
Please.
Please socialize.
He got my tail.
Oh, no, he doesn't.
Is this thicker?
Yes.
Is this a tail thicker?
All right, who is still needs...
Mine is almost 15 pounds.
He just needs two more.
Okay, Dragoon here.
Okay, I have food for you.
He has four more.
I have food for you.
Wait, what do I consipate?
Oh, he's behind me.
Oh, he's eepy.
Are you eepy?
Stop playing with the stick.
There's other things to play.
This is like, the stick is like the video game.
Mom, I don't want to play with the other paws.
I want to play with my stick.
God, Mom, I can't just pause stick playing.
You don't understand.
You don't understand, mom.
Oh, my God.
Oh, dragon!
Oh, blackie!
No!
Dragon, please!
Stop playing with the stick!
Dragon!
That's right.
Dragon, no, no, no.
Don't mess with me.
Go, go, go, go.
Go.
You were the other kids.
Okay.
I'm going to help.
That's right.
Get over here.
Get out!
Get out of here!
Nice.
Wait!
Your junior has four!
Okay, that's not my child.
No, but...
Oh, never mind.
I don't care.
Yeah, I don't care.
That's not mine.
That's not my kid.
Oh, who cares?
Yeah, that's...
Oh, thank God.
As long as not Dragoon, it's fine.
Come on.
Get a little bit.
You just need two more pounds and you'll be fine.
You'll be big and strong and be alpha just like...
me go on you need four more pounds just stop sleeping okay
aqua needs to keep eating aqua has a full pound thissy your
child is a runt we should have let that child your child is
anorexic what the heck bro what happened feed your child
don't let better dragon take all the food
wake that child please wake up wake him up It's like, oh, we
have to eat.
Let's see.
Wake your child up and make her eat.
She doesn't need to sleep.
She needs to put weight in that body.
Don't constipation has so much sleep.
Just wake up.
It's like 60% sleep.
What the fuck?
Girl, you have one pound left.
Wait, the child.
Come on, here, eat.
I'm going to wake your child.
Oh, my God.
Fucking sleep peep-y Yeah, he's like passed out, dude.
Bro, I'm sleeping now.
It's sleeping time.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me,
me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Sorry, am I snoring lightly?
So it was like, wait, V-Tubers are not the best parents.
I don't know what I thought Andrew, it's healthy again Oh,
they're eating, they're eating Your pups have grown It's at
15 pounds Yes!
Yes!
Yay!
Journey to summer home They no longer need the dens Now it's
time to journey Take them to your home base for the summer
You need a spot with sun and shades Okay, all right, pick
them up, it's time Moutou must select a new site on the map
then lead them.
Okay, find a patch of wolf to tell your pups to hide.
They will be saved while they're away.
Okay, I'm just gonna pick them up.
Fuck this.
Yeah, fuck it.
I'll just pick them up.
We're still rendezvous spot.
Is that the grass?
I think so.
Right?
That is, right?
Yeah, that's the grass.
Okay, I'm gonna go.
Yeah, there's one that's super close.
Yeah.
All right.
Get over here.
you up dragon and she's like mom those are picking me up is
for kids don't pick me up don't pick me up this is
embarrassing mom i'm not i'm grown up now i'm two months old
now mom you're embarrassing me mom not in front of my
friends mom my friend oh god mom you wouldn't get it you
don't understand mom god constipation doesn't let his mom
pick him up all the time
god why can't you be cool like his mom just leave me alone
man god i was shy lily was my mom no you did not say that
You did not see that, Trigoon.
You did not.
You would have been named constipation.
It's not what you wanted.
If she was your mom.
You want constipation.
That would have been your name if it wasn't for me.
It's not that bad, mom.
No one bought this constipation.
Yeah.
God.
It's not even...
Mom, it's pronounced...
Constipation.
Yes, he has constipation.
It's Latin for peace.
God, you're so insensitive, mom.
Mom, please, it's 2024.
Grow up.
When Petra and Dragoon got lost.
Okay.
Wait, what?
They lost their child for like five seconds.
I need to break.
Fuck.
Wait, get your child!
How did you lose your kid?
Oh my god.
Alright, I'm gonna hold it until, like, they get better
Dragoon over here.
Go get your child, come on!
Mom, no, I'm running away!
I like how someone's like, Mom, it's 2024!
Constipation is a common name!
Okay.
Get off the times, mom.
Okay, here, this is my Moran Nebu site.
It means peace in Latin.
Summertime hard.
Let's go!
Yippee!
You can loaf around.
I think this is a good time to come.
Yeah, I think I've been constipated for long enough.
That was fun.
a great time.
This was so good.
I'm so glad we opened the ceremony, but I've still been
looking for them.
Yeah, but I'm still been looking for them.
We've still been looking and pissing.
Yeah, we feel like, what are we doing?
Alright, one last hale, yes.
That's a group.
Come over here.
Let's go.
Get over here.
We hale together.
Trial was un-mourished.
Trial-mourished.
No food Thanks for joining me literally.
I'm glad so far.
I'm glad we picked this game I'm glad we picked this game to
play together And when you suggested this game, I was like
this is the one this is it We need this game.
I need this fucking game Thank you to the shrimp goons for
teaching us how to play.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you so much shrimp gooning, Inc.
Thank you shrimp goons Incorporated for teaching us.
We were able to get this far because of all you.
Our puppies would have died like four minutes in.
We wouldn't even have puppies.
still been so fucking lost look that is why we are
supervisors not workers we are very exactly we're very good
at supervising we're very bad at doing anything else
decisions yes yes we are the decision people this game is so
good thank you 500 hour andes thank you finding us a damn
and babies and taking care of our children and feeding them
and fighting off the the predators we really appreciate it
thank you lily for joining me and thank you for having me it
was so good until next time i hope we play more together
till next wolf quest anniversary edition
All that dragons.
All that fucking love there.
Bye.
I'm going to talk to my channel.
Oh, bye.
Bye bye.
I'm going to close the server.
Goodbye for real.
You will never reunite with your children ever again.
Oh, I forgot to save.
That would be...
Oh, our hard work gone.
I know.
No way.
Okay.
saved i saved okay all right i'll see you later i'll see you
bye bye bye oh my god that was so fun we guys had uh a fun
time with with lily and i uh we went in blind we were so
confused so i'm glad we ended up opening the server to the
people who actually have experience with this game
the children um i hope you guys had a really fun time
watching it was uh really a fun time uh collabing with lily
uh let me swap real fast all right oh my god i think like
the exciting thing uh about it is just like meeting lots of
new people and like uh collabing with so many new people uh
but yeah i had an amazing time with lily today and uh just
messing about oh my god oh if you're not for those who
aren't for those who didn't see the new community post for
members for the member goon I'm currently working with a
Minecraft team right now on making a community server a
dragoon community Minecraft server so I'm really happy
because like Gumi was the one that hit me up with that like
not hit me I'm sorry connect ask Gumi because like she's
really uh she's in like um all these like SMPs and stuff and
like Minecraft SMPs like the which one was it the really big
one which one was it that has like Spanish integration she's
in like those SMPs and she actually was in a dream SMP as
well and she did like the um MCC as well and has won the MC
so she has she has like so many connections with um with
like the uh Minecraft uh Minecraft people and she yeah the Q
SMP yeah Gumi's actually in the QSMP.
So I asked her for like, um, if she knows somebody who can
make the, uh, Dragoon members Minecraft server for us.
So she connected me with, um, with this team that, uh, with
this team that has done like Minecraft servers, um, and, uh,
Minecraft maps for like a lot of like Minecraft content
creators, as well as, uh, like a lot of like SMPs and stuff
for content creators, they were the ones that made the
twitch rivals uh minecraft maps and minecraft servers for
twitch rivals so like she connected me up with them and
they're currently working on the server at the moment for
member goons uh this minecraft server will only be for the
uh current dragoon member so be like synced up to the
members list um but and like i made a post asking for uh for
like what your input is and what you're looking for in the
server so if there's any plugins you want app will look like
so like we're hoping to have like in place where when you
log in you'll be dropped into the lobby area so we're um we
need to get them like features of what they want so if
you're a member goon please check out the member community
post to give your input on what you want for the minecraft
server um also tomorrow it is the charity uh stream slash
auction I'm really excited about the auction.
I'm really thankful for the help of little man.
Yes, little man.
They've been helping me a lot with setting all the auction
stuff.
They've actually helped me with like getting in touch with
like Tiltify and like the the Brain and Behavior Foundation,
Research Foundation.
They've been working really hard on setting everything up
for us and listing up all the auction items.
I'm super duper excited.
I'll give you guys those who are the member stream i can
give you guys a sneak peek of like some of the items uh let
me see if i can find um i'll give you a sneak peek of some
of the items so for example this will be in the auction one
of them because the other one's for me but here are some of
the items that will be in uh the auction so like a two of a
kind the other one is for me so technically two of a kind
plush um and uh they are currently setting it up at the
moment so like some stuff to look forward to uh the stream
itself it's just it's gonna be very random there'd be like
some stretch goals and everything um and uh um i'm still
trying to figure out what to do on the stream but uh the
auction might start uh tonight or before the stream starts
and um lil mad told me to let you guys know that if you're
looking to bid on the item, you need to have a Tiltify
account and you have to link a payment method and your
address on your account.
Your account has to be registered on Tiltify and also have
payment method linked as well as your address registered.
So you'll be able to bid on the items.
So like, I'm just needing it.
guys to remind you guys about it how a charity stream be um
i will try my best to stream as long as i can i won't i
don't want to force myself too hard to stream a very long
time but the auction itself would be around will be uh will
last all the way for 24 hours uh that is my hope um so if we
do or for or two days i want the auction to be around two
days uh so people have as much time to bid it and everything
so i'm gonna try and have the auction itself be two days um
there is around 30 items in the auction and i'm super duper
excited uh i'm super duper excited for the auction and hope
that um a lot of you guys enjoy some of the items that's on
there um but yeah i hope you guys had a great time um with
the collab with lily and uh enjoyed just like uh me meeting
lots of new people.
Next week, I will be...
I know I have one collab that's finalized.
Well, we haven't decided the game yet.
We haven't decided the game yet.
But I reached out to Chibi Doki if they wanted to collab
with me because I thought it would be funny because we're
both Doki's.
So next week, I'm still deciding the game.
So I'll be collabing with Chibi Doki next week.
Other than that, there is so much work.
so much work i'm always so busy yesterday i spent all my day
just working i'm always super nervous uh regarding collab i
know like i'm i always like reach out to people for collab
but also i'm always super nervous when collabing because um
i i you know when it's like new people i don't know what the
chemistry is like so like um i try to pick games out that i
feel would work the best between us and everything and uh um
so i It's so, it's always so nerve-wracking before a collab
because I don't know what the chemistry is going to be like
and everything like as like a one-to-one thing.
And, um, and I'm just happy that Lily enjoyed herself and we
all had a great time.
Also, so my mod reminded me, new merch!
Yes!
New merch!
The lunar, yes, sorry, the lunar new year is over.
I know the lunar new year is over, but we have lunar new
year.
merch look I'm still getting a hand of planning merch in
advance okay it's very difficult so the lunar new year merch
will be it will be on sale on March 3rd at 5 p.m.
PST there will be 200 limited edition bundles that come with
a signed postcard and only the red pocket envelopes the
pre-order for all of this will be up for a month and then
everything but the red pocket envelopes will be off the
store so red pocket envelopes would be uh in the store
forever but everything else will be off the store because
it's limited it's only there for pre-order um so yeah so
there's a put a little acrylic stand put in sticker and red
pocket envelopes snapshots will be in the bundle only um
that's not limited but the limited ones will be the signed
postcards okay so that is the lunar new year merch i think
those are all the updates um yes i know i might be late i've
been thinking of a super chat thank you thank you new year
may be over but year of the dragon is still for 10 more
months exactly we think like that ivy thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you um no the red pocket will be
on the store forever everything else is it will be like gone
after the pre-order is done um but yeah i hope you guys had
a great time um i have to work now after this means i have
to do the charity event work stuff but anyway as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing interview except for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye